l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à madame annie genevard
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
permettez-moi en préambule d'adresser
mes félicitations à tous ceux qui ont
été élus ce dimanche les municipales les
municipales ont confirmé que les
républicains sont le premier parti en
nombre d'élus et de villes de plus de
9000 habitants dirigée par la droite et
ses alliés confirmant ainsi la force et
la légitimité de notre ancrage
territorial
cela prouve que nous avons un lien fort
avec la vraie vie des français avec la
démocratie du quotidien c'est
précisément ce qui fait défaut à votre
majorité qu'il subit un très lourd
revers électoral
je veux dire aussi que dans le contexte
de poussée écologique que nous
connaissons nombreux sont les maires de
notre famille politique qui se sont fait
élire avec des propositions écologiques
pragmatique mais non dogmatique
je veux leur rendre hommage pourtant
l'abstention a été massive pour un
scrutin qui d'habitude mobilise les
français se désintéressent pire il se
méfie de la politique et des politiques
dans ce contexte le report des élections
départementales et régionales envisagé
par le président de la république ne
peut qu'aggraver la défiance les
français y verront à juste titre un
tripatouillage destiné à servir
exclusivement les intérêts d'un clan qui
craindraient là une nouvelle déroute
électorale à un an de la présidentielle
monsieur le premier ministre pouvez vous
nous dire si ce report est dans vos
intentions
merci le genevois la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur monsieur lille
veut dire mesdames et messieurs les
députés
madame la députée vous avez commencé
votre question en adressant vos
félicitations républicaines à toutes
celles et ceux qui à l'issue du scrutin
dimanche dernier ont été élus
conseillers municipaux dans les plus de
4000 communes dans lesquelles ce second
tour devait encore être organisées
je voudrais madame la députée m'associer
aux félicitations républicaines que vous
venez d'adresser aux élus et peut-être
si vous m'y autorise et élargir un peu
les remerciements et les félicitations à
tous ceux qui se sont présentés aux
élections je suis certain que vous les
angles oubliez aussi dans votre remarque
mais vous savez comme moi vous savez
comme moi la difficulté de la vie
politique vous savez comme moi la valeur
de l'engagement et beaucoup de nos
concitoyens se sont engagés dans ces
élections municipales parfois avec
l'espoir de gagner parfois sans espoir
de gagner mais pour défendre des idées
une vision et ils l'ont fait avec ce
sens de l'engagement civique qu'il faut
saluer le suffrage ne leur a peut-être
pas toujours été favorables
il n'empêche ils ont été devant les
électeurs et ils ont voulu participer à
ce débat public important je pense
qu'ils méritent d'être salués de la même
façon nous devons saluer et je suis
certain que vous les anglos biais aussi
tous ceux qui ont rendu ces élections
possible les agents de l'état les agents
municipaux les bénévoles nos concitoyens
qui tiennent des bureaux de vote et
nous nous faisons souvent la réflexion
tous ensemble de ce que les élections
nous paraissent évidentes nous
paraissent naturelles
la vérité c'est qu'elle ne sont
possibles que parce que il y a dans
notre pays des femmes et des hommes qui
bien entendu participe à l'élection en
votant mais qui consacrent du temps à
leurs concitoyens et à faire vivre cet
exercice démocratique les élections
qu'elles soient municipales cantonales
régionales nationales les élections dans
une démocratie c'est un moment essentiel
et pour répondre à votre question madame
la députée on ne fixe pas la date des
élections vous le savez comme moi à sa
convenance
c'est la loi si vous avez l'air surpris
c'est la loi qui fixe le terme du mandat
pour lequel un élu a été élu et on ne
peut pas choisir le moment de l'élection
mais il est admis et vous le savez comme
moi que dans l'hypothèse dans
l'hypothèse madame la député ou un motif
d'intérêt général un motif d'intérêt
général justifie que la durée d'un
mandat soit allongé il est possible dans
ce cas là si un motif d'intérêt général
le justifient de reporter la date prévue
de l'élection c'est ce qui s'est passé
certains s'en souviennent ici en 2007 et
2008 pour l'élection municipale puisque
par consensus mais au lieu de crier
laissez-moi terminer ma réponse vous
allez voir ça va vous intéresser par
consensus par consensus
il a été admis que si les élections
municipales se tenait en 2007
cela venait percuter l'élection
présidentielle d'une façon qui n'était
pas correcte et donc la loi sous le
contrôle du juge constitutionnel la loi
sous le contrôle du juge constitutionnel
a permis l'extension des mandats des
mers pendant un an jusqu'à 2008
parce que le motif d'intérêt général a
été jugé suffisant pour que soit décalé
d'un an
l'élection municipale
si madame la députée et le si est
important si il était envisagé une
transformation une transformation des
compétences des périmètres des
collectivités territoriales si il était
envisagé et si un consensus suffisant
apparaissait alors peut-être
aurions-nous le motif d'intérêt général
peut-être aurions-nous le motif
d'intérêt général mais j'observe une
chose madame la députée c'est que ceci
est ainsi important c'est que le
contrôle du juge en la matière est
totale complet et c'est tant mieux
et c'est tant mieux et c'est que cela ne
peut se passer que par une forme de
consensus je dirais pas d'unanimité mais
de consensus qui est important le
consensus
au moment des élections c'est important
je me souviens d'ailleurs de certains
qui juste avant le premier tour me
disais que décalé une élection sans
consensus
ça n'était pas possible je m'en souviens
très bien valable a dit peter
j'en ai un souvenir parfait et donc je
ne change pas de ligne
les élections doivent intervenir à des
dates prévues si un motif d'intérêt
général d'intérêt général suffisant se
dessine alors il peut être envisagé de
les décaler je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre
madame la députée merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
je retiens de ce que vous venez nous
dire que vous posé deux conditions
s'il ya un motif d'intérêt général et
s'il ya consensus
donc j'espère que
les deux conditions seront remplies de
notre côté du côté des républicains nous
sommes très clairs nous ne sommes
absolument pas favorable au report des
élections des belles filles qui est
réputé la parole à monsieur michel
larive monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le préfet de seine
saint denis a mise en demeure
monsieur le maire de stains d'effacer
une partie de fresque d'une fresque sur
le mur de sa commune et plus précisément
le mot policière dont l'allocution
violences policières qui est il pour se
constituer en censeur de la création
artistique
quelle est cette république qui autorise
ces hauts fonctionnaires à bafouer la
liberté d'expression on ne peut on peut
ne pas être d'accord avec le message
d'une oeuvre artistique mais nul ne peut
s'arroger le droit de l'entraver la
liberté d'expression est protégé par
l'article 11 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et sanctuariser dans
notre constitution
si vous acceptez cela monsieur milice il
vous faudra alors censuré les tâches de
georges brassens renaud jacques prévert
et bien d'autres
aucune démocratie moderne aucun état de
droit digne de ce nom ne peut ranger
engendrer une telle infamie
seuls les états totalitaires du passé et
du présent
agissent de la sorte vous ne pouvez pas
être charlie et utiliser les grands
ciseaux de madame anastasie en même
temps déjà lors de la révolte populaire
des gilet jaune l'expression de
l'indignation des femmes et des hommes
qui subissaient votre politique
d'exclusion s'exprimer au travers
d'oeuvres artistiques
vous les avez toutes détruites qu'auriez
vous préférez à une et à une expression
artistique et pacifique la france
berceau de lumière reçoit votre outrage
comme une violence extrême contre sa
liberté
quel est votre objectif monsieur le
ministre après l'invisibilisation d'une
partie de notre population
souhaitez-vous les effacer de notre
mémoire collective
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député la france pays des lumières
l'avez vous dit ce n'est pas les états
unis la police française ce n'est pas la
police américaine et ne confondez pas
tout n'évoquez pas monsieur le député la
liberté de parole pour prêter soutien à
cette fresque cette fresque faisant le
parallèle entre messieurs traoré
monsieur floyd en parlant de violences
policières cette fresque monsieur le
député est tout simplement insupportable
elle est insupportable pourquoi parce
que un long entretien un amalgame
pernicieux comme votre question elle est
insupportable car à laisse penser que
l'état la république ferait usage la
force de manière illégitime
ça n'est pas le cas monsieur le député
le mot policiers le mot policier n'a
rien à voir
à côté de ceux de racisme ou de violence
car nos policiers monsieur le député
lutte à chaque heure chaque jour chaque
nuit contre les violences contre le
racisme
il lutte aussi contre le risque en
théorie ce en prenant eux mêmes tous les
risques
monsieur le député alors oui à st à
stains en seine-saint-denis sur tout le
territoire national nos forces de
l'ordre répondent présents et nos forces
de l'ordre quand tel projet
quand elle protège nos concitoyens
monsieur le député elle refuse cet
amalgame honteux entre violences
policières et la réalité de ce qu'elles
font chaque jour et monsieur le député
oui à juste titre le préfet a reçus à
leur demande les organisations
syndicales et à juste titre il a demandé
à monsieur le maire de stains de revenir
sur cette fresque qui est peinte sur un
bâtiment municipal et qui porte la haine
l'amalgamme qui porte au fond
l'insupportable de faire en sorte qu'il
n'y aurait pas en france une police
républicaine alors qu'à chaque instant
monsieur le député elle sera là à vos
côtés et aux côtés de tous les
parlementaires ici pour défendre la
république
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame michèle de vos couleurs
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur julien de normandie
ministre chargé de la ville et du
logement
monsieur le ministre alors que les
expulsions hivernales sont interdites du
1er novembre au 31 mars
les dates de cette trêve hivernale ont
cette année été repoussée tout d'abord
jusqu'au 31 mai puis jusqu'au 10 juillet
prochain date correspond à la
correspondant à la date de la fin
d'urgence sanitaire lié à l'épidémie de
coronavirus dans notre pays
cette mesure associée à d'autres mesures
en faveur des personnes privées de
logement était une absolue nécessité
pour lutter contre la propagation du
virus
al'approche de la date fixée pour la fin
de la trêve des expulsions les acteurs
de la solidarité manifestent leur
inquiétude en 2018
ce sont 15 1983 foyers qui avaient été
expulsés soit une hausse de 41 % en dix
ans alors que plus de 1,5 millions de
nos concitoyens peine tout au long de
l'année à payer leur loyer
cinq cent mille d'entre eux ont été
privés de toute ressource durant le
confinement et entre 500 1000 et 800000
ont subi des baisses de revenus
si le gouvernement a débloqué des moyens
considérables pour amortir les
conséquences de cette crise plusieurs
milliers d'entreprises ont d'ores et
déjà dû cesser leur activité et le
nombre de personnes privées d'emploi
devraient bondir au dessus de 10% dans
les mois à venir
ce sont autant de personnes qui auront
davantage de difficultés à assumer leur
charge tous les mois dans ce contexte
monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures le gouvernement entente
il prendre pour éviter que de nouveaux
ménages risquant d'être expulsé viennent
grossir des 143 milles personnes
recensées comme étant sans domicile fixe
le gouvernement tente il notamment
répondu favorablement la demande des
acteurs de la solidarité et prolonger la
trêve des expulsions jusqu'au printemps
2021 je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur julien de normandie ministre
chargé de la ville et du logement mais
si monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
de vos couleurs
comme vous l'avez dit toutes remises à
la rue est un drame c'est un drame
humain et soyez en sûr madame la députée
mon ministère met équipe
les élus locaux les associations font
tout absolument tout pour éviter ces
remises à la rue
alors pendant la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement et cette majorité avons
pris des mesures exceptionnelles
notre main n'a pas tremblé lorsqu'il
s'agit de décaler à deux reprises la
trêve hivernale et en parallèle nous
avons ouvert plus de 20000 places en
réquisitionnant des hôtels
ces vingt mille classes visait à mettre
à l'abri les plus fragiles elles
venaient s'ajouter aux places déjà
existantes
ce qu'il fait que hier soir près de 180
mille personnes ont été mises à l'abri
par l'état les associations les élus
locaux 180 mille personnes c'est plus
gros que la ville de saint-etienne que
la ville de toulon le parlement examine
en ce moment même la fin de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
ce qui signifiera la fin de régime
exceptionnel et dans ce contexte de
retour au droit commun
la trêve hivernale ne peut une nouvelle
fois être prolongée pour autant alors
que le virus circule toujours dans notre
pays nous partageons exactement le même
objectif que les associations que vous
avez mentionné c'est à dire qu'aucune
personne ne se retrouve à la rue dans ce
contexte c'est pourquoi avec l'accord du
premier ministre je vais donné
instruction aux préfets par circulaire
dès cette semaine de s'assurer que seuls
les procédures d'expulsions locatives
adossés à des possibilités de relogement
opérationnel ne soient mises en oeuvre
ceci encore une fois afin de tout faire
pour que les remises à la rue sans
possibilité de relogement ne puisse
avoir lieu
et si la procédure d'expulsion locative
ne peut être mise en oeuvre
les propriétaires pourront solliciter
l'indemnisation de l'état tel que prévu
de par la loi
c'est cet accompagnement individualisé
que nous mettons en place sous remercie
madame la députée
madame le député quelques secondes merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la réponse apportée me paraît
être à la hauteur des enjeux
je vous en remercie merci s'il vous
plaît
s'il vous plaît la parole est un
monsieur eric ciotti merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
notre jour notre justice est aujourd'hui
malade de sa politisation le poison de
la suspicion gagne chaque jour du
terrain
cette suspicion s'est nourrie
naturellement des déclarations récentes
de madame houlette faisant état de
pressions fortes de sa hiérarchie dans
la sphère fillon cette suspicion trouve
également sa source dans la procédure un
jury sentent diligentée dans le total se
crée au mépris de tous les droits de la
défense par le parquet national
financier à l'encontre de nicolas
sarkozy et de dizaines d'avocats
surveiller de façon scandaleuse
cela est extrêmement grave
la motivation politique deux procédures
se situe à en marge du cadre juridique
habituel est posée le court sans doute
et le visage peut-être de notre
démocratie a n'a été changé de façon
générale le pnf s'apparente de plus en
plus à une juridiction d'exception
cela n'est pas sain créé pour les
affaires financières complexes
il s'est transformé en lieu de tract
politique avec une prédilection et une
célérité particulière pour les opposants
et une lenteur et une clémence constante
pour les amis du pouvoir actuel et passé
alors monsieur le premier ministre
qu'entendez vous faire pour que ne se
fabriquent plus dans des officines des
scandales d'état
entendant vous faire droit à la demande
du président nicolas sarkozy qui réclame
la saisie de l'inspection des services
judiciaires pour faire la lumière sur
des pratiques indignes d'un état de
droit
merci monsieur le député la parole à
madame nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
ciotti
je comprends le trouble qui a été
suscitée par les propos de madame la
procureure l'ancien procureur national
financier devant la commission denquête
vous le savez le président de la
république a dès le 20 juin saisi le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
puisqu'il est le garant de
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
sur l' affaire des fadettes que vous
relatez qui a été révélée par un
hebdomadaire récent j'ai moi même saisi
demandé un rapport à madame la procureur
général de paris si des
dysfonctionnements apparaissent je
devrais être destinataire de ce rapport
dans l'est de manière imminente si des
dysfonctionnements apparaissent
je n'hésiterai pas à saisir l'inspection
générale de la justice pour faire la
lumière sur ces questions là je crois
pour autant monsieur le député qui
serait périlleux de vouloir aujourd'hui
supprimé le parquet national financier
le parquet national financier le pnf est
devenu un instrument majeur de notre
souveraineté judiciaire
les succès qui ont été obtenues dans les
négociations sur airbus sur google et je
pourrais citer bien d'autres dossiers en
font aujourd'hui un acteur
incontournable reconnu dans sa
légitimité son expertise en france comme
à l'international
je crois qu'il est très important
également de rappeler monsieur le député
que le gouvernement auquel j'appartiens
n'a jamais donné d'instruction dans des
affaires particulières d'abord cela est
interdit par la loi
cela est ensuite interdit par l'éthique
que nous portons et c'est très important
c'est ce que je viens de répondre
monsieur jacob j'ai dit que j'allais en
fonction des éléments que va me donner
madame la procureure générale sollicité
une inspection si des dysfonctionnements
apparaissent
je voudrais également dire monsieur le
député qu'il ne faut pas faire
d'amalgamé entre les
les instructions individuelles qui n'ont
pas lieu et les demandes d'informations
que je peux légitimement demander pour
conduire la politique pénale du
gouvernement
il aurait été anormal par exemple que
dans l' affaire des fadettes je ne fasse
pas il demande même la parole adam
jennifer de temmerman
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
il y a deux ans à peu près 1
un collègue à 6 désormais sur les bancs
des ministres me disais que si
l'écologie était importante pour les
citoyens
les verts auraient remporté les
élections après dimanche je me dis qu'il
y à au moins trois leçons à tirer devant
la convention citoyenne hier le
président semble avoir pris la première
nous aurons donc un acte 2.1 la seconde
je crois qu'il attend le bon moment
quel est le bon moment maintenant nous
sortons d'une crise sanitaire qui
impacte notre économie un niveau sans
précédent
preuve du manque de résilience dimanche
une vague verte a déferlé sur la france
mais le taux d'abstention record
interroge nous le savions déjà avant
la défiance des français en leur
représentant continue de grandir
une autre voie a été proposée sans issue
pourquoi les politiques publiques manque
de cohérence
on va t'aider galim on gratifie l'état
on vote la fin de l'exploitation des
hydrocarbures
on prolonge certaines autorisations le
manque de cohérence en lisible l'action
publique et politique
la confusion empêche la perception du
changement pour les citoyens nous sommes
tous les mêmes et ça n'a rien de positif
c'est la troisième leçon à tirer
les français ont besoin d'un cap clair
atteindre les objectifs de développement
durable n'a jamais été aussi difficile
est aussi impératif qu'aujourd'hui c'est
ce que démontre la crise du coc vide 19
ce sont les mots du président de la
république le 28 mai dernier à l'onu
l'agenda 2030 est une grammaire commune
la boussole qui nous permettra de
réorienter notre politique au sortir de
la crise un plan cohérent lisible basé
sur les partenariats l'agenda s'adresse
à tous
nous parlementaires devon et voulons
nous en saisir avec le groupe d'étude
que je préside avec dominique potier sur
les eaux d'aidé nous travaillons sur une
proposition de loi systémique réaliste
et trans partisane
monsieur le premier ministre
soutiendrez-vous cette initiative mais
dit il aime le débuter la parole et
abala emmanuelle wargon secrétaire
d'état auprès de la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés madame de tp madame la
députée jennifer de temmerman
vous l'avez dit les français souhaitent
un cap clair et le président l'a exprimé
hier devant les 150 citoyens de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat il a
fixé un cap en matière économique en
matière écologique en matière sociale en
matière de souveraineté
il a reconnu que ce pari de faire
confiance à 150 citoyens tirés au sort
ni spécialiste ni militant était un pari
réussi avec des propositions ambitieuses
il s'est engagé à en reprendre 146 et à
les transmettre au parlement
le parlement sera maintenant pleinement
saisi assemblée nationale et sénat sur
ces propositions
nous proposerons un projet de loi sur
d'autres seront insérés dans le plan de
relance pour que notre modèle économique
ne soit ni productiviste produire pour
produire sans tenir compte des limites
de la planète ni celui de la
décroissance dans lequel il n'est pas
possible de créer de la richesse et donc
il n'est pas possible de soutenir notre
modèle social
vous le voyez le cap a été fixé par le
président l'écologie est au coeur de ce
programme et cela rejoint madame la
députée la préoccupation générale autour
des objectifs de développement durable
qui sont portées par ma collègue brune
poirson et sur lesquels nous sommes
pleinement engagés vis-à-vis des nations
unies pour que ces objectifs soient
pleinement au coeur de nos politiques
publiques
vous attendiez un signal vous attendiez
un cap il a été donné il sera dans la
dernière partie du quinquennat le
président de la république aura
l'occasion de s'exprimer sur ce sujet
mais d'ores et déjà c'est le parlement
qui fera son office
en reprenant ces propositions merci
madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur olivier faure
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je veux d'abord vous
adresser mes félicitations républicaines
pour votre réélection à la mairie du
havre mais vous conviendrez parce qu'il
ya un mais conviendrez avec moi que
l'arbre ne veux pas cacher la forêt
jamais non jamais un président de la
république n'avait subi un tel revers
lors d'élections municipales
hmm hmm
[Applaudissements]
réalité laisser monsieur faure continuer
s'il vous plaît monsieur faure à la
parole
allez-y chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît continuez chers
collègues même la clarification opéré au
second tour je veux parler de vos
alliances avec la droite même cela n'a
pas permis d'endiguer la victoire du
bloc social et écologique
alors qu'allez vous faire de cette
défaite les couloirs bruce mais c'est
moins un remaniement gouvernemental que
les français attendent qu'un remaniement
de la politique que vous conduisez
l'acte 2 devait être plus sociales
on a eu les réformes de l'assurance
chômage et des retraites
l'acte iii devait être écologique mais
déjà la course de lenteur est engagé
avec les propositions de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat il ya cependant
un point
un point sur lequel nous voulons être
d'accord donner plus de pouvoirs et de
moyens aux collectivités locales
mais cela ne peut pas être au prix d'un
chantage et d'un tripatouillage
électoral moyen nouveau contre report de
l'élection régionale
la démocratie ne se marchande pas sur ce
principe républicain là au moins
j'aimerais être certain que nous
partageons la même vision
monsieur le premier ministre alors je
vous pose cette question très simple et
il dans vos attentions de chef du
gouvernement de reporter les élections
régionales immersif relègue la parole
est à mme adams iba n'diaye secrétaire
d'état porte parole du gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le député monsieur le député
fort permettez moi à mon tour à la fois
de féliciter de manière républicaine
l'ensemble des maires qui ont été élus à
l'occasion de ces élections municipales
mais également de remercier l'ensemble
des marques et des assesseurs des
présidents de bureaux de vote qui ont
permis la tenue de ces élections dans un
contexte au combien difficile cette
élection je crois que le premier
renseignements qu'on peut en tirer c'est
celui d'une abstention massive qui doit
collectivement nous interpeller sur
l'ensemble des bancs de cette assemblée
et c'est au fond un ouvrage sans cesse
sur le métier que nous devons porter
vous avez évoqué la question au fond du
résultat de ces élections et de ce que
cela pouvait souligner je conviens avec
vous que cette élection a été pour la
majorité une déception et nous aurions
souhaité faire davantage bouger les
lignes mais votre perception des
élections municipales passées je vous là
vous me laisse assez songeuse une autre
leçon que je retiens c'est le message
sur la question écologique qui nous a
été adressé une aspiration à vivre mieux
dans un monde qui accepte enfin la
transition écologique comme un impératif
pour tous c'est la raison pour laquelle
le président la république a eu des mots
très forts à l'occasion de la convention
citoyenne signifiant ainsi qu'il
comptait dans leur quasi-intégralité
reprendre sans filtre les propositions
de la convention citoyenne afin qu'elle
soit examinée non seulement par le
parlement mais également pour que le
gouvernement puisse par voie
réglementaire à l'occasion d'un prochain
conseil de défense écologique les mettre
en oeuvre de manière rapide
nous ne partageons pas la même vision de
l'écologie les visions de l'écologie que
ce gouvernement porte est une écologie à
la fois de progrès une écologie de
responsabilité une écologie des
territoires et enfin une écologie de
justice qui ne laisse personne sur le
bord du chemin et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce gouvernement est fier de
porter haut et fort les couleurs de
l'écologie dans notre pays
je vous remercie mr
si le ministre la parole est à madame
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
la parole à madame huguette kenya et à
elle seule
mais si dc présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire
madame la ministre le président de la
république a reçu hier matin les
conclusions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat et je veux saluer ici le
travail de ces citoyens qui venait du
lot en passant par paris et de toutes
les régions de france
les travaux qu'elle a entre me sont
ambitieux et nous sommes déterminés à
aller au bout de la transformation
écologique du pays
le président de la république je
rappelle le plus jeune président de
l'histoire française a été au rendez
vous des attentes de la convention
puisqu'il a choisi de reprendre la quasi
totalité des propositions faites
il a confirmé qu'il irait au bout de
cette démarche qu'il est et continuera
d'être à la hauteur des enjeux
démocratiques et écologiques de notre
époque
il a fait des annonces majeures en
annonçant 15 milliards d'euros sur deux
ans pour la conversion de notre économie
et un moratoire sur les centres
commerciaux
nous avons pris un risque politique est
fait un pari démocratique inédit avec
cette convention c'est pari s'est avéré
payant
la convention assuré tisser du lien
entre les français et les institutions
et elle a montré que l'écologie était
une affaire de tous et non d'une vague
cette convention citoyenne est une
occasion historique de prendre des
décisions qui seront date d'avancer
ensemble au delà des partis pour
l'intérêt de tous est de lutter
efficacement contre le réchauffement
climatique
ensemble nous devons maintenant ajouter
un symbole d'engagement écologique fort
à notre drapeau français pour les
générations futures notre majorité sera
au rendez-vous et y apportera sa
contribution
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous
préciser les contours du projet de loi
que présentera le gouvernement
à la fin de cet été je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame brune poirson
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
la transition écologique et solidaire
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée cdh n'a effectivement vous
l'avez souligné cette convention
citoyenne pour le climat est un
changement majeur un changement surtout
deux méthodes et qui incarne aussi la
façon dont vous nous voulons faire de
l'écologie l'écologie on peut la faire
en dressant les citoyens les uns contre
les autres ou on peut la faire en
décidant que c'est à la recherche du
consensus et que c'est ainsi que nous
pourrons avancer et avoir des avancées
très concrète et je sais madame la v8 et
combien avec tous les députés qui sont
ici à 6 dans cet hémicycle
eh bien vous voudrez continuez vous
aurez à coeur d'aller de l'avant et
effectivement la question de la méthode
qui et qui fait partie de la question
que vous venez me poser est absolument
essentiel d'abord une méthode de travail
qui sera inédite vous les parlementaires
vous allez pouvoir continuer à améliorer
aller dans le sens des propositions de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
est bien en travaillant avec des groupes
de suivi qui vont réunir des ministres
mais aussi des parlementaires et et des
représentants de cette convention
citoyenne ensemble vous pourrez examiner
comment et dans quelle mesure nous
mettons en oeuvre les mesures de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
d'autre part vous aurez aussi un rôle
majeur à jouer majeur parce que le
président l'a dit la démocratie
délibérative ne remplace pas la
démocratie représentative bien au
contraire
et s'il vous transmets les propositions
sans filtre et bien c'est votre
légitimité celle à tous ici celle qui
est issu des urnes
l'expertisé que vous avez acquises qui
permettront de transformer ces
propositions de loi et plus ensuite nous
travaillerons comme nous le faisons
aujourd'hui à la mise en oeuvre concrète
de ces propositions de la convention qui
citoyenne pour le climat ce ne sont pas
les propositions uniquement du
gouvernement ce sont des propositions
issues d'un consensus de france est
représentative elles nous appartiennent
à tous et nous la mettrons ensemble en
oeuvre
électivement merci madame la ministre la
parole était monsieur fabien roussel
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre le 19 mai dernier
les 194 états membres de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé ont adopté une
résolution faisant des futurs vaccins
contre le coronavirus des biens publics
mondiaux
plusieurs chefs d'état ont émis un
souhait comparables et il faut bien sûr
s'en réjouir mais dans les coulisses on
le sait les labos privés des pays se
font la course
espérant être les premiers à déposer un
brevet pour ensuite gagner de l'argent
sur le dos de cette pandémie
rappelons-nous l'exemple du traitement
contre le sida commercialiser des 96 par
un petit groupe de laboratoires
américains
il fut accessible seulement dix ans plus
tard sous forme de génériques aux pays
en développement est encore au prix
d'une lutte courageuse menée par le
président nelson mandela à laquelle
l'industrie pharmaceutique n'a pas
hésité à faire un procès cette menace
existe toujours aujourd'hui
la représentante américaine à d'ailleurs
affirmé lors de cette assemblée mondiale
de la santé qu'un mac qu'un vaccin ne
pouvait pas être gratuit et que cette
résolution je la cite encore envoie un
mauvais message aux innovateurs
voilà pourquoi nous devons aujourd'hui
tous ensemble obtenir des actes concrets
pour sortir les futurs vaccins contre le
coc vite 19 de la logique de profit et
d'en garantir l'accès universel
c'est d'ailleurs le sens d'une pétition
lancée à l'échelle de l'union européenne
par la gauche unitaire européenne et 13
parties dont le nôtre
monsieur le premier ministre quelles
initiatives comptez vous prendre en
france comme au niveau européen pour que
les futurs traitements contre le
coronavirus ne fassent pas l'objet de
brevets et soit accessible immédiatement
sous forme de génériques pour tous les
pays et tous les peuples et en france
d'une prise en charge à 100% par la
sécurité sociale
monsieur le premier ministre faisons en
sorte que le vaccin deviennent un bien
commun de toute l'humanité
merci
merci monsieur le député la parole est
un monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député nous le
savons et malheureusement nous le
regrettons il n'existe pas à ce jour de
médicaments permettant de lutter
spécifiquement contre lui convient de 19
je le dis avec prudence car j'ai bien
compris que dès lors qu'on parlait de
médicaments et de covile 19 les passions
plus parfois que la raison donnée le
sentiment prévaloir
ce qui est certain c'est que aucun
traitement spécifique créée
spécifiquement si j'ose dire
pour lutter contre le coc vite 19
n'existe aujourd'hui l'espoir l'espoir
aujourd'hui réside dans la conception et
dans la production d'un vaccin
et là encore monsieur le député
observons ensemble que lorsque l'on
parle de vaccins y compris dans le pays
de pasteur
on se heurte souvent à des passions
beaucoup plus qu'à l'expression de la
raison je le dis parce que le
gouvernement que j'ai l'honneur de
diriger s'est beaucoup engagée dans la
lutte pour la vaccination
et vous le savez nous avons pris des
décisions rendues obligatoires
un certain nombre de vaccins qui ne
l'étaient pas jusqu'à présent parce que
nous croyons profondément à la
prévention et nous croyons profondément
aux effets bénéfiques de la vaccination
et de la vaccination obligatoire
vous m'interrogez donc sur la dimension
de bien public mondial que devrait
revêtir le futur vaccin dès lors que il
aura été démontré qu'il correspond bien
aux exigences d'efficacité bien entendu
mais de sûreté qui sont naturellement
exigible le président de la république a
fixé cet objectif vous le savez il a
indiqué que
nous voulions un accès au vaccin pour le
plus grand nombre et que ce vaccin
puisse devenir un bien public mondial
c'est d'ailleurs parce que cet objectif
a été fixé que nous avons lancé
l'initiative dit acta avec d'autres
plateformes de coopération mondiale pour
accélérer et intensifier la recherche le
développement l'accès et la distribution
équitable du vaccin et d'autres
traitements thérapeutiques et
diagnostiques vitaux nous participons
quand je dis nous c'est la france
participe pour un peu plus de 500
millions d'euros à différentes
organisations internationales qui ont
pour vocation la recherche ou la
distribution du vaccin et qui auront
pour mission de faire en sorte que ce
vaccin le moment venu puisse être
distribué dans de bonnes conditions vous
connaissez ces institutions le gavi
united' par ailleurs dans les travaux de
négociation c'est important que la
france conduit sous l'égide de la
commission européenne sur les questions
relatives des précommandes
nous avons indiqué notre vigilance et la
vigilance que nous souhaitions faire
prévaloir sur les clauses relatives à
l'accès facilité au meilleur prix pour
tous au meilleur prix je comprends que
l'on puisse imaginer que la production
mondiale soit gratuite mais la vérité
c'est qu'elle a un coût et ce qui nous
importe vous le savez ce qui nous
importe c'est que le vaccin puisse être
distribuée dans les meilleures
conditions et que lorsque c'est
nécessaire
sa production et sa distribution puisse
être facilité par un effort financier
collectif parce que la solidarité
internationale parce que la solidarité
internationale en matière de vaccination
ce n'est pas simplement aider des gens
qui ont besoin d'être aidés c'est
s'aider soi-même c'est s'aider soi-même
pour lutter contre l'épidémie au niveau
mondial il faut que chacun puisse jouer
sa partie et pour que chacun puisse
jouer sa partie il faut transparence et
solidarité c'est exactement la position
de la france qui a été défendu par le
président de la république
rappelé par le ministre des solidarités
de la santé à genève cette semaine et
qui le sera incessamment par notre pays
dans une course qui s'annonce longue
longue parce que heureusement les
initiatives multiples fleurissent
partout dans le monde et cette recherche
dont vous dites monsieur le député
qu'elle ne serait motivée que par le
souci de brefs t et ensuite de dégager
du profit
elle se justifie aussi cette compétition
parce que dans beaucoup de pays du monde
d intelligence exceptionnelle
exceptionnel cherchent se mobilisent
pour aller le plus vite possible
eh bien il faut que cette recherche qui
avance vite soit aidé dans la durée et
des dans la durée pour que nous
puissions tous disposer rapidement de ce
vaccin c'est la position de la france je
ne crois pas que sur ce sujet nous
soyons en désaccord mais c'est un art
d'exécution qui est devant nous est
contée sur le gouvernement comptait sur
l'ensemble des pouvoirs publics français
pour faire prévaloir ses positions merci
monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à monsieur vincent ledoux
merci monsieur le président madame play
ministre de la recherche
l'enfer n'existe pas pour les animaux
prétendait victor-hugo l'enfer n'existe
pas par les animaux existent sont déjà
alors certes la conscience animale ne
cesse de progresser très doucement trop
lentement va en tout cas elle progresse
et on scrute à chaque fois les petits
reculs qui peuvent se nicher dans les
détails et ce fut le cas le 17 mars 2001
lorsqu'un décret au code rural est venu
amendé en quelque sorte
l'expérimentation animale vous y avez
répondu et nous vous remercions pour
autant nous souhaitons obtenir
aujourd'hui une réponse publique devant
la représentation nationale ne peut pas
admettre que nous puissions vendre un
animal de compagnie à des laboratoires
pour l'expérimentation animale
c'est tout juste impensable mais en même
temps il nous apparaît pour le groupe
agir ensemble utile de vous interroger
sur votre position relativement aux
méthodes substitutives à
l'expérimentation animale
86% des français sont favorables à
l'interdiction de l'expérimentation
animale dès lors qu'il y a des méthodes
substitutives et puis deuxièmement il y
a le droit d'objection de conscience
pour les chercheurs
les jeunes chercheurs qui ne veulent pas
en passer par l'expérimentation animale
s'est déjà mis en oeuvre dans des pays
européens
donc nous souhaiterions aujourd'hui
madame la ministre connaître votre
agenda en la matière et savoir si ces
questions seront à l'agenda de notre
assemblée
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole et à madame frédéric vidal
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche et de l'innovation
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vincent ledoux non la
provenance des animaux utilisés à des
fins d'expérimentation scientifique
n'est pas ouverte à tous les trafics et
merci de me donner l'occasion de le
rappeler aujourd'hui publiquement
c'est ce que l'on appelle une fausse
nouvelle
et c'est très important que nous
puissions aujourd'hui en parler c'est
une fausse nouvelle pourquoi parce que
le code rural interdit que l'on puisse
vendre des animaux de compagnie que l'on
puisse vendre des animaux pour des fins
d'expérimentation
c'est très clairement indiquées et ça
l'est d'autant plus depuis le décret du
17 mars
lorsque nous avons transposé la
directive européenne
nous avons précisé que les dérogations à
l'utilisation d'animaux fournis par des
établissements agréés ne pouvait être dû
qu'à des fins scientifiques ou au cas où
les établissements ne serait pas en
capacité de fournir les animaux et ce
que nous a dit la communauté européenne
c'est que nous devions enlever cette
dérogation supplémentaires et revenir au
strict droit c'est à dire que en aucun
cas on ne puisse pour des raisons
commerciales
parce que des établissements agréés sont
dans l'incapacité de produire les
animaux à des fins de recherche
scientifique et bien que nous avions
dans ce cas là
le droit d'avoir d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement c'est ça que nous
avons fait dans ce décret du 17 mars
c'est exactement l'inversé de ce dont
nous avons été accusé ces accusations
elles vont à l'encontre de la cause
animale
nous avons travaillé bien sûr avec le
centre national de l'expérimentation
animale avec des représentations des
associations de défense des animaux et
c'est elle même qui ont porté cette
parole très très forte merci madame la
ministre monsieur les buts et il y a
ceci dit 26% des animaux qui tous les
ans viennent
or des listes à gré donc j'aimerais
savoir d'où ils viennent et deuxièmement
connaître votre agenda sur l'objection
de conscience et sur les méthodes
substitutives je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole à
madame marie noëlle battistel merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
le groupe socialiste et apparentés salue
les travaux remarquables de 150 citoyens
tirés au sort sur un panel de deux cent
cinquante cinq mille membres est engagé
dans la convention citoyenne pour le
climat qui confirme l'urgence de changer
de modèle
lundi le président de la république
s'est dit ouvert à ouvrir une discussion
sans filtre sur 146 des 149 propositions
issues de ces travaux l'efficacité de la
convention citoyenne les annonces du
président de la république suscite donc
un espoir cependant nous ne pouvons que
constater qu'un grand nombre de ces
propositions ont déjà été portées par
notre groupe depuis 2010 est grand plan
de rénovation énergétique avec la prime
pour le climat augmentation de la part
du bio dans les restaurants scolaires
renégociation des traités commerciaux
reconnaissance du crime déco sites
légaux gontassi conditionnalité des
aides
l'encadrement de la publicité des
produits alimentaires malsains et j'en
passe que nous avions d'ailleurs
présenté aux membres de la convention
citoyenne en janvier dernier notre plan
de relance pour un rebond économique
social et écologique totalement
financier présenté le 9 juin reprend
d'ailleurs ses nombreuses idées et
propose de faire des collectivités
territoriales les chefs d'orchestre de
la lutte pour la transition énergétique
mais depuis 2010 9 monsieur le premier
ministre toutes nos copies 2017 toutes
nos propositions
en phase avec les aspirations des
français vous les avez rejeté je
comprends donc qu'il est plus facile
d'accepter de bonnes idées lorsqu'elles
viennent des citoyens que lorsqu'elle
émane de votre opposition mais que de
temps perdu alors que l'urgence
climatique s'impose chaque jour un peu
plus les 150 citoyens vous démontre que
la société est prête
les résultats du scrutin de dimanche
dernier et la percée d'un blog social
écologique vous prouve que les
collectivités sont prêtes les
parlementaires eux aussi sont prêts et
vous le dise par leurs propositions
alors vous avez l'occasion de donner les
premiers signes lors de l'examen du plf
r3 en acceptant nos propositions visant
à financer ces mesures
monsieur le premier ministre y êtes vous
pris merci madame la députée la parole
tant la brûle poirson secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée battistel avoir des
idées c'est bien les mettre en oeuvre
c'est mieux au ministère la transition
écologique et solidaire au ministère la
transition écologique et solidaire quand
on ouvre les placards il tombe des
centaines voire des milliers d'idées qui
avait été très justement porté par le
gouvernement précédent mais jamais mise
en oeuvre
regardez par exemple fessenheim ensuite
vous me parlez vous me parlez de
travailler avec vous demander au
gouvernement de travailler avec les
oppositions par les ont donc avec les
collègues de votre groupe vous verrez
combien nous avions bien travaillé
ensemble sur la loi anti gaspillage pour
une économie circulaire et je crois que
c'est une loi de consensus que nous
avons construit ici avec l'ensemble des
députés
assis sur ses bancs et de façon
collective
enfin vous parler d'action mais qui a
décidé de mettre en oeuvre la convention
citoyenne pour le climat c'est le
président de la république
c'est un pari démocratique fou c'est
aussi les propositions qu'il a reprise
intégralement à l'exception de trois
sans filtre c'est aussi des propositions
qui seront transmises ici mais pas que
transmises ici et je sais madame la
députée qu'avec les députés de votre
groupe et bien vous aurez à coeur de
continuer
à les enrichir mais de nous aider aussi
d'accompagner la mise en oeuvre parce
que bien évidemment construire un projet
de loi c'est important le mettre en
oeuvre derrière ça l'est tout autant
aussi je j'engage les élus de votre
groupe qui viennent de rentrer dans les
communes et bien de travailler
lorsqu'ils seront eux aussi dans les
associations qui représentent des
collectivités locales et bien qu'ils
travaillent main dans la main avec nous
pour les mettre en oeuvre et donc vous
voyez de la part du gouvernement une
volonté de créer une écologie fondé sur
le consensus et non les sur les
oppositions et surtout une écologie
fondée sur l'action et le rassemblement
et non pas l'un vers merci madame la
ministre
la parole à monsieur raphaël berger
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
justice hier soir à 23 heures le premier
éco site de l'histoire a été commis hier
soir un crime contre le climat a été
orchestrée par le gouvernement
hier vous avez étouffé fessenheim au
bénéfice du dogme et au détriment de
l'environnement
si le président de la république
souhaite interroger l'intégration de
l'ecosite dans le droit français
je souhaite à l'heure vous interrogez en
retour madame la ministre de la justice
sur son application à l'action du
gouvernement
hier matin dans la mise en scène verte
du jardin de l'elysée le président de la
république organisait son alibi
embrassant la quasi totalité des
propositions portées par les membres de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
mais hier soir il se confondait et
abandonnait la lutte contre les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et le
réchauffement climatique par le symbole
politiciens de l'arrêt du cnpe de
fessenheim préférant l'idéologie au
pragmatisme
vous privilégiez les mesures d'affichage
à la réduction effective des gaz à effet
de serre il n'ya pas d'écologie sans
respect de l'homme député de fessenheim
je veux ici en ce jour si particulier
pour la france et son avenir énergétique
salué le travail remarquable conduit par
les salariés de la centrale nucléaire
pendant 43 ans
je sais votre vive émotion cet instant
vous avez rendu un site industriel en
parfaite état de sûreté très performant
couvrante façon décarbonés jusqu'à 90 %
de la consommation électrique alsacienne
au fond depuis 40 ans vous avez fait
bien plus pour protéger l'environnement
que ceux qui s'en arrange tatort le
monopole
chers collègues si l'écologie se mesure
en actes alors la véritable force de
protection de l'environnement se trouve
ici sur ces bancs de l'hémicycle
du côté de la droite responsable et
pragmatique soucieuse des résultats et
qui ne sacrifie pas les atouts français
merci monsieur le député la parole à
madame emmanuelle wargon secrétaire
d'état auprès de la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés monsieur le député raphael
chez les berges
oui hier nous avons en responsabilité
accompagner la fermeture du deuxième
réacteur nucléaire de fessenheim
nous avons fait ce choix en
responsabilité avec deux engagements
extrêmement fort
le premier c'est un engagement de
trajectoire énergique équilibré et
décarbonées équilibrée parce que plus de
70 % de notre électricité vient
aujourd'hui du nucléaire et que pour
traiter aussi le dossier de bure le
dossier de 6 g aux jeux c'est comme vous
que la question de l'avenir des déchets
nucléaires est une question qui là aussi
est une question importante qui
nécessite une réponse une deuxième le
deuxième engagement que nous avons pris
c'est un engagement de respect et
d'accompagnement des salariés des sous
traitants et des habitants moi aussi je
voudrais saluer comme vous le
professionnalisme des salariés de
fessenheim le professionnalisme des
salariés d'edf et de dire que nous ne
les laisserons pas tomber
vous nous avez accusé d'indifférence
mais ça n'est pas la vérité depuis deux
ans ce gouvernement accompagne le
territoire de fessenheim le gouvernement
accompagne ce territoire avec un projet
de territoire à 700 millions d'euros
et pas plus tard pas plus tard qu'il ya
quelques jours une entreprise qui
s'appelle européenne de biomasse annoncé
son intérêt pour la création d'emplois
d'énergie décarbonnée jusqu'à 700
emplois c'est facile d'invectivés mais
où êtes vous à où êtes vous quand nous
menons les combats localement ou
êtes-vous qu'on nous réunissons le
comité territoire où êtes vous quand
nous cherchons des franges locaux alors
l'invectivé et facile
l'action est difficile pas de défaitisme
sur le territoire de fessenheim eux ça
n'est pas à la hauteur des habitants ça
n'est pas à la hauteur de la démocratie
merci madame la ministre
s'il vous plaît avant de lui donner la
parole je suis heureux de souhaiter la
bienvenue à madame valérie six devenu le
23 juin en remplacement de monsieur
francis vercamer député de la 7e
circonscription du nord
bienvenue vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé j'ai été
alerté par des élus et des habitants de
ma circonscription sur l'explosion du
phénomène de l' usage détourné du
protoxyde d'azoté ses cartouches grise
qui contiennent ce gaz et servent
habituellement de recharge pour siphon à
chantilly garnissent nos rues trottoirs
parcs et caniveaux le drame c'est que
nous assistons impuissants à une
généralisation massive de ce phénomène
qui ne se cantonne plus aux départements
du nord mais s'étend dorénavant à
l'ensemble du territoire
nous sommes face à une consommation
d'ampleur par des jeunes d'un produit
psychoactif euphorisant est loin d'être
anodin vertige détresse respiratoire
séquelles neurologiques et cardiaques
entraînant déjà la mort ce phénomène
d'addiction est facilitée car ce produit
est en vente libre pour une somme
modique
en l'état actuel de notre droit certains
maires ont pris des arrêtés interdisant
la consommation et la vente aux mineurs
du protoxyde d azote arrêtés souvent
bien difficile à faire respecter
il me semble alors indispensable de
légiférer sur le sujet vous le savez une
proposition de loi de ma collègue
valérie létard est cosigné par plus de
90 sénateur a été adoptée à l'unanimité
au sénat le 11 décembre dernier d'une
première réponse reposant sur la
prévention
vous avez su cheminée pour comprendre
les enjeux de la problématique du
protoxyde d'azoté
aussi lorsque ce texte sera inscrit à
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée nationale
j'espère que la même concorde pourra
voir le jour
médecin familles élus locaux attendent
quand responsabilités nous fassions
évoluer la législation pour incriminer
l'incitation à la consommation est
interdite à la vente du protoxyde
d'azoté pouvez vous monsieur le ministre
nous garantir l'engagement du
gouvernement pour que la co-construction
que vous aviez salué au sénat se
poursuivent et que nous aboutissions une
réponse législative
face à ce problème de santé publique je
vous remercie sur prologue
la parole à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame la députée valérie six experts le
thema de vous souhaiter la bienvenue
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale je garde d'excellents
souvenirs de votre prédécesseur francis
vercamer à qui voudrait bien passer mon
amitié et le bonjour vous interrogez
madame la députée sur la question du
protoxyde d azote
le protoxyde d'azoté ça a l'air sympa
comme ça sur le papier on l'appelle le
proto on l'appelle le gaz hilarant ça
paraît sympa ce fou rire quasi assurés
qui va durer quelques secondes une douce
euphorie un peu de narcose parfois des
hallucinations et puis au bout de
quelques secondes retour à la normale on
se sent comme un sou neuf
on n'a pas les séquelles de la
consommation d'alcool ou ou d'autres
super fiant et du coup on recommence
cartouches après cartouches
ça a l'air sympa le protoxyde d azote
puisque d'ailleurs ceux utilisés dans
les hôpitaux et que on peut se dire que
finalement si on en donne aux patients à
qui on fait des actes invasifs c'est que
ça doit pas être très dangereux ça
paraît sympa mais en fait vous l'avez
dit madame la députée c'est dangereux
l' usage détourné de protoxyde d azote
est un usage dangereux troubles
neurologiques vertige confusion troubles
psychologiques addictions en bonne et
due forme
et puis des séquelles des séquelles qui
peuvent être neurologique qui peuvent
être lourdes et puis madame la députée
dans le pire des cas le mésusage la
consommation du protoxyde d azote
notamment comme vous en avez parlé
s'agissant des cartouches de chantilly
ou d'autres endroits on peut trouver ses
capsules en accès libre finalement peut
conduire à des brûlures mortelle de la
trachée des bronches des voies
respiratoires et du des cas de décès
dans des conditions très difficiles
deux jeunes qui pensaient que c'était
sympa et donc sans danger
madame la députée vous l'avez dit
vous-même il y à la sénatrice je crois
que madame valérie létard qui a fait
adopter à l'unanimité une proposition
parlementaire de loi le gouvernement
s'était engagé à l'époque à retravailler
et à enrichir cette proposition de loi
avant qu'elle n'intervienne dans le cas
du débat parlementaire à l'assemblée
nationale
comptez sur moi pour tenir cette
promesse
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à wallemme laurence dumont merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre le 20 avril dernier
benyamin nétanyahou et benny ganz ont
signé un accord de gouvernement
d'urgence nationale
celui ci prévoit l'annexion de la vallée
du jourdain le grenier à blé de la
cisjordanie qui représentent 30% des
territoires palestiniens cette décision
prise avec l'aval de l'administration
américaine est inacceptable dangereuse
et illégale des intellectuels des
associations des citoyens du monde
entier se sont exprimés révolté par
cette annonce qui nient le droit
international et bafoue celui des
palestiniens
la communauté internationale hors états
unis s'élèvent contre cette négation de
l'état de palestine et évoque les
risques en matière de paix dans la
région
le ministre des affaires étrangères a eu
des mots forts notre représentant aux
nations unies aussi l'union européenne
le secrétaire général des nations unies
la ligue arabe
de nombreux pays européens se sont
élevées contre ce plan et menacent
israël de mesures en retour mais les
mots ne suffisent plus des actes forts
doivent être posées nous avons été
nombreux
120 parlementaires de toutes
sensibilités a signé un courrier au
président de la république afin d'avoir
une réponse forte de la france et de
l'europe
nous appelons à des sanctions immédiates
en cas d'élection nous appelons à une
reconnaissance conjointe par l'évêque 27
membres de l'union européenne de l'état
de palestine et à défaut cette
reconnaissance doit pouvoir se faire de
manière unilatérale par la france
monsieur le premier ministre
quelles actions concrètes la france et
l'europe vont elles mettre en place pour
empêcher dès demain la mise en oeuvre du
plan gantz netanyahu trump est sauvé la
solution à deux états avec un état de
palestine
merci madame la députée la parole est à
madame amélie dimanche à la secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'europe
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée comme vous l'avez dit le 17 mai
dernier un nouveau gouvernement a été
investi par le parlement israélien et
qui sera conduit en alternance par
benyamin nétanyahou puis en 2021 par
benny gantz nous entendons travailler
bien sûr avec ce gouvernement dans un
esprit d'amitié et de coopération comme
cela a toujours été le cas et nous
sommes engagés aux côtés d'israël pour
la sécurité régionale et dans tous les
domaines qui font la richesse de cette
coopération
mais nous sommes très attentifs aux
décisions qui seront prises au sujet des
territoires palestiniens car vous l'avez
dit l'accord de coalition permet
l'annexion d'une partie la cisjordanie à
partir de demain
et depuis son investiture le premier
ministre benyamin nétanyahou n'a cessé
de réaffirmer sa détermination à
s'engager au plus vite dans cette voie
quel que soit son périmètre je le redis
ici solennellement au nom du
gouvernement et du président la
république cette décision est une
violation grave du droit international
elle contribuerait attiser les tensions
et compromettrait gravement la solution
à deux états qui est la seule la seule
capable de garantir la paix et la
stabilité à long terme dans la région
elle irait donc directement à l'encontre
de l'intérêt des israéliens comme des
palestiniens alors la priorité pour la
france en lien avec nos partenaires
européens et arabes
c'est bien sûr d'éviter qu'une telle
situation se produise nous mobilisons
les membres de l'union européenne
nous appelons le gouvernement israélien
à s'abstenir de toute musique mesures
unilatérales et en particulier
l'annexion notre message est clair nous
pourrions faire beaucoup avec israël si
nous coopérions mais à l inverse
nous ne reconnaîtrons aucun changement
aux lignes de juin 1967 qui ne seraient
agréé par les deux parties et compte
tenu sa gravité
une décision d'annexion ne pourrait
rester sans réponse jean yves le drian
n'a dit si israël décidé d'aller de
l'avant dans le processus d'annexion
cela aurait des conséquences sur ses
relations avec l'union européenne et ses
états membres
notre position est connue le cadre c'est
le droit international la méthode c'est
la négociation est l'objectif ce sont
deux états viables dans la paix la
sécurité au sein des frontières sûres et
reconnues de 1967 avec jérusalem pour
capitale 2
chacun de ces états ce sont les
principes que nous suivons avec
vigilance avec détermination en ami des
israéliens et des paroles de madame
frédérique meunier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la santé nous venons de
vivre une crise sanitaire sans précédent
les soignants ont été exemplaires
j'ai d'ailleurs rencontré à plusieurs
reprises le personnel de l'hôpital de
brive
son directeur sans oublier le secteur
privé soyez certains que je mesure leurs
difficultés quotidiennes
cependant nous devons tirer les
enseignements de cette crise car
l'épidémie de coronavirus qui n'est pas
encore terminé a montré les failles de
notre système de santé en particulier
dans les hôpitaux
plus d'un an après le début d'un
mouvement de grève dans ces structures
il est enfin apparu urgent au
gouvernement de montrer son intérêt pour
certaines des demandes des soignants
après avoir annoncé en 2018 le plan de
transformation du système de santé qui a
abouti au plan ma santé 2022 que le
président de la république vient de
déclarer peu efficace vous annoncez
votre troisième plan santé oui mes chers
collègues le troisième vous avez réussi
le tour de force de vouloir faire naître
l'espoir et provoqué le désespoir
une re valeur une revalorisation de la
rémunération des soignants est
indispensable mais il faut une vision
d'ensemble pour améliorer les conditions
de travail pour sauver l'hôpital public
le 25 juin lors des niches
parlementaires le groupe l'est
républicain a présenté deux propositions
de loi que vous avez balayé d'un revers
de main la première redonner des marges
de manoeuvre aux hôpitaux pour organiser
les services de soins en effet cette
période a démontré que lorsque l'hôpital
retrouve des marges de manoeuvre et que
l'administration est volontaire les
équipes sont capables d'organiser son
fonctionnement de manière efficace
la deuxième proposition concerne et le
gel des fermetures de lits et de
services hospitaliers pour une durée de
12 mois chez moi en corrèze il y allez
faisons et les 10 e ou vous situez vous
alors monsieur le ministre je vous pose
la question le ségur de la santé
auxquels j'ai participé en corrèze
sera-t-il l'anxiolytique que fut le
grand débat pour les gillet
mne je remercie merci chalet la parole à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé madame la
députée frédérique venu monnier d'abord
laissez-moi vous remercier puisque vous
l'avez dit vous-même vous avez participé
aux travaux du ségur et je voudrais le
dire je considère que sur des enjeux
comme l'hôpital que l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale participe
interpelle fasse remonter ces
propositions c'est ce qui nous permet de
progresser collectivement car si nous
regardons un peu en arrière madame
meunier vous avez fait le bilan des
trois dernières années
d'abord peux pas vous laisser dire que
plus dans la république aurait dénigré
la loi ma sortie 2022
il a dit tout le contraire il a dit que
c'était une excellente loi et qu'il
fallait en accéléré la portée et les
conséquences sur l'ensemble du
territoire
en réalité madame la députée si on
regarde un petit peu en arrière
moi j'ai cherché j'ai cherché même très
très loin en arrière j'ai cherché aussi
loin que je pouvais trouver dans les
archives du ministère
à quel moment est-ce qu'il avait été
proposé une revalorisation des salaires
pour plus d'un million et demi de
salariés qui s'occupent de nous quand on
est malade à hauteur de 6 milliards
d'euros c'est la proposition qui était
faite aux syndicats
figurez vous madame la députée que j'en
ai pas trouvé
[Applaudissements]
et croyez moi j'ai bien cherché croyez
moi j'ai bien cherché par ailleurs vous
poser la question de la réorganisation
de l'autonomie dans les territoires si
j'ai bien compris de la capacité de
créer de la fluidité entre la ville et
l'hôpital entre le sanitaire et le
médico social
comment est ce qu'on fait davantage
confiance aux équipes comment est-ce
qu'on s'appuie sur le dynamique des
équipes de santé des dynamiques des
équipes médicales
comment est ce qu'on fait vivre la
démocratie sanitaire comment est-ce
qu'on évite d'être trop du haut vers le
bas
quand est-ce comment est ce qu'on est
capable d'expérimenter de changer les
modes de financement d'articuler encore
une fois le sanitaire et le médico
social
mais adam la députée c'est exactement
l'objet de ségur et c'est exactement ce
que nous allons proposer à l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux qui sont
nombreux
réunis autour de nous pour travailler
sur la réforme du système de santé d'ici
à quelques jours
je me réjouis que par avance vous soyez
réjouis des propositions que nous ferons
et encore une fois c'est elles sont
accueillies dans le consensus je pense
que après la période d'épidémie que nous
avons vécu les français l'apprécierait
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
madame nicole du bre chirat ma question
s'adresse à monsieur laurent quittera
ses skis monsieur le ministre l'épidémie
coronavirus pardon a pour conséquence
des difficultés économiques et sociales
majeures
selon pôle emploi le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi inscrits en
catégorie a en france avait enregistré
au mois d'avril pendant le confinement
sa plus forte hausse
huit cent quarante trois mille personnes
par rapport à mars
c'est le plus haut niveau jamais atteint
depuis l'enregistrement en 1996 les
raisons principales sont l'absence
d'offre l'emploi le non renouvellement
des cdd le gouvernement a mis en place
très vite le chômage partiel permettant
de couvrir 84 % du salaire pris en
charge par l'état et l'assurance chômage
huit millions et demi de salariés y ont
eu recours soit une personne sur trois
pour une durée d'une de deux semaines et
demie le coût est estimé à 80 milliards
d'euros 40 milliards d'euros par dont
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
pour lutter contre la crise ont été
efficaces car les chiffres du chômage
ont baissé de 3 3% en deux mois en juin
une diminution de la prise en charge de
l'état à 60% été mise en place cette
activité partielle
de longues durées entrera en vigueur en
juillet l'enjeu de ce dispositif reste
le même que sa version de droit commun à
savoir éviter des licenciements dans les
entreprises dont la pérennité n'est pas
remise en cause mais qui sont confrontés
une réduction d'activité durable
cela s'applique à l'automobile
l'aéronautique et aussi à l'hôtellerie
aux restaurations et au tourisme
le recours à ce nouveau dispositif est
soumis à deux dispositions un accord
collectif majoritaire d'une part les
entreprises bénéficiant de l'activité
partielle de longue durée qui devront
maintenir une activité à 60 % minimum
il est indispensable de garder un niveau
de protection élevé pour éviter une
nouvelle vague de licenciements
septembre il nous faut réfléchir aux
nouvelles formes de travail utilisées et
apprécier pendant le confinement
ceci implique de réfléchir à la place et
à l'organisation du travail dans la
société pour accompagner les salariés
les entreprises
monsieur me disent vous pouvez vous nous
éclairer sur les orientations concernant
les nouvelles modalités merci positif
d'allégations compte la parole à
monsieur laurent pietrasinski secrétaire
d'état chargé de la protection de la
santé des salariés
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés madame la députée
nicole du brescia d'abord un mot pour
excuser maladies du travail qui est
actuellement à brest sur un job dating
sur l'apprentissage
vous savez que le gouvernement a pris
des mesures énergiques pour faciliter et
dynamiser l'apprentissage il est
important que madame le ministre du
travail
en témoigne sur le terrain concernant
votre question sur le dispositif
d'activité partielle
vous l'avez rappelé nous avons su
transformer efficacement le dispositif
existant et tout ça en quelques jours
pour protéger depuis le début du mois de
mars des millions de salariés français
je crois que c'était important de
rappeler ici l'ensemble des actions qui
ont été réalisées par le ministère du
travail la dgt et la direccte au service
des salariés des entreprises françaises
avec les partenaires sociaux dans le
cadre des réunions organisées avec le
président de la république et le premier
ministre nous avons pu préciser les deux
dispositifs d'activité partielle que
vous avez évoquées dans votre question
qui seront en
oeuvre dans quelques jours et quelques
semaines d'abord le premier c'est
l'activité partielle de droit commun qui
sera maintenu et adapté à partir du 1er
octobre
ce régime d'ailleurs je tiens à préciser
vous l'aviez dit aussi il sera toujours
plus protecteur que les dispositions
actuelles de droit commun
l'indemnisation du salarié sera comprise
entre 100 % et 72 % de son salaire net
antérieur et 60 % de cette indemnisation
sera remboursée aux entreprises le
second dispositif s'était d'ailleurs
plutôt le coeur de votre question c'est
celui d'activité partielle vie de longue
durée dont l'objectif est de mettre en
place des solutions alternatives pour
inciter les entreprises qui vont
redémarrer mais qui sont
vraisemblablement et qui le seront dans
certains cas notamment dans les secteurs
que vous avez évoquées en sous-activité
madame la députée et lorsque ces
entreprises sont en sous-activité nous
voulons qu'elles maintiennent les
salariés en poste ou voulons qu'elle
préserve l'emploi et pour cela nous
avons mis en place ce dispositif
d'activité partielle est ambitieux mais
les unes du mois de juillet la parole
est à monsieur frédéric reiss
merci monsieur le président chers
collègues maxence adresse au premier
ministre nous avons tous en mémoire les
manifestations de sympathie envers nos
soignants avec d'improbables concerts et
des applaudissements fenêtres de nos
villes monsieur le premier ministre le
15 avril vous avez évoqué avec raison je
cite l'incroyable dévouement de tout le
personnel soignant
après l'annoncé par le président de la
république fin mars
depuis l'hôpital de campagne de mulhouse
d'une prime exceptionnelle pour
accompagner financièrement la
reconnaissance envers les soignants très
bien mais la mise en oeuvre de cette
preuve promesse s'est révélée complexe
la somme allouée variant dans les zones
géographiques et les statuts les
critères de 40 départements et de 30
jours n'ont pas été compris et suite à
la polémique sur les disparités des
primes le ministre olivier ferrand a
annoncé des ajustements mon département
est éligible à la prime maximale de 1500
euros
mais à l'heure où les soignants
découvrent leur fiche de paye de juin
c'est une petite musique de déception
qui monte de leurs rangs j'ai le
témoignage d'infirmières
qui sur la base du volontariat ont été
en secteur qu'ovide du 11 avril au 11
mai et qui n'ont pas droit à la prime
elles ont abandonné leur boulot pour
aller dans un établissement inconnue
avec un seul masques par jour avec des
sur blues artisanale sans parler de
l'absence de sur chaussures elles ne
l'ont pas fait pour de l'argent mais
elles ne comprennent pas aujourd'hui le
conseil d'état est saisi pour rupture
d'égalité
ces primes ont suscité beaucoup
d'incompréhension et les blouses
blanches sont toujours dans une colère
noire
que répondez-vous aux infirmiers
médecins aides soignants et aux
directeurs d'hôpitaux qui sont plus
qu'embarrassé pour décider de
l'attribution ou non de primes à leurs
personnels
ne serait ce pas un cadeau empoisonné
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
monsieur le député raze cnn au mali vous
pouvez me contacter mme écrire je
regarderai personnellement la situation
personnelle de cette infirmière parce
que je vous le dis vous êtes député du
bas rhin
la situation est très simple le bas rhin
fait partie des quarante départements ou
comme un demi million plus d'un demi
million de soignants quel que soit leur
statut leur la blouse qu'il porte ont
été valorisés d'une prime de 1500 euros
nets défiscaliser été socialisés je peux
pas vous dire autre chose
donc si vous me dites qu'une infirmière
est allé exercer pendant la crise duco
vide dans un service hospitalier dans
département du bas rhin
je ne vois pas pourquoi ne relèverait
pas de stream donc je vous propose qu'on
puisse tout simplement aborder cette
question là peut-être est-ce plus simple
pour résoudre cette situation s'il ya
des erreurs nous le verrons que j'allais
dire de jeter l'opprobre sur une prime
qui a le mérite de récompenser en
urgence un grand nombre de soignants
même si j'entends que dès lors qu'il ya
une équité territoriale qui s'explique
par l'inéquité avec laquelle le virus a
frappé département ou autres
départements et bien j'entends que ça
puisse forcément faire faire débat et
croyez moi nous avons revu les critères
un nombre important de fois nous avons
contacté chaque directeur d'arrêt c'est
en définitive nous avons permis aux
directeurs d'hôpitaux qui le
souhaitaient d'attribuer dégradation de
la prime dans les hôpitaux qui ne
bénéficiaient pas de la prime maximale
de la même manière monsieur le député
tous les soignants dans les ehpad
percevront au moins 1000 euros quel que
soit leur statut à nouveau au moins 1000
euros de primes défiscaliser
désocialisés elle sera de 1500 euros
dans les quarante départements qui ont
été touchés et j'en profite parce qu'il
me reste une vingtaine de secondes pour
redire
l'engagement du gouvernement à ce que
les départements puissent rapidement à
leur tour accorder une prime pour les
aides à domicile
le département de meurthe et moselle
vient de le décider le département de
meurthe et moselle mais oui monsieur le
député ce n'est pas l'état partout
l'état payait partout
l'assurance-maladie payer ne serait-ce
une partie du salaire la prime a été
accordé je crois que c'est important que
nous fassions tout cet effort pour
remercier celles et ceux qui ont pris
soin de nous depuis des mois
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur françois ruffin dimanche
dernier les 550 français la conférence
citoyenne pour le climat rendu leurs
conclusions à 98%
ces citoyens tirés au sort voter pour un
moratoire sur la 5g une technologie qui
considèrent je les cite sans réelle
utilité dans son discours hier le
président de la république n'a pas dit
un mot
silence radio pouvez-vous nous assurer
que les enchères pour les fréquences 5 g
prévu pour septembre sont bien geler
voire annulés oui ou non
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame agnès pannier
ménagers secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
rufin je vais vous répondre très
simplement comme la suède comme la
finlande comme l'allemagne comme les
états unis comme la chine comme la corée
comme la nouvelle zélande
oui nous allons lancer les enchères de
la 5g
oui nous avons pris nos responsabilités
sanitaires environnementales
nous nous sommes appuyés sur les agences
l'ansès l'arcep
la mfr et nous lançons pour être tout à
fait sûr que nous sommes tout aussi
responsables que les autres états qui
ont sont entraîne de lancer cette
technologie qui est essentiel à la
compétitivité de notre pays
une mission qui est confiée à l'igpn à
l'igas au cgedd et eaux cge pour nous
assurer que nous sommes bien aux
meilleurs standards des pratiques de
suivi environnemental et sanitaire
cette réponse est très simple nous le
faisons pour le pays nous le faisons
pour notre industrie nous le faisons
pour les français merci madame la
ministre monsieur rufin vol là vous me
jurez l'enfumage
il ya une semaine il ya une semaine
98 % des citoyens réunis viennent nous
dire que c'est une technologie inutile
sans réelle utilité
le président la république dit je
reprendrai tout ya trois jokers et là on
vient nous dire aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a
pas de moratoire sur avec 5 g que les
enchères sont lancées
ça veut dire que tout ce qui a été fait
là par les citoyens c'est du bidon c'est
du bidon hommes
oui oui cela vous assignez dessus le
président la république il n'a pas dit
ça hier le président n'a pas dit un mot
là-dessus je le vis n'est qu'il y avait
anguille sous roche
vous l'avez levé avec une et tma la
bannière une hache-- mais franchement là
ce à quoi ça servait de faire une
conférence citoyenne sur le climat au 98
% des citoyens viennent dire on est
contre la 5g
veut novateur la juge et vous vous
lancer les enchères comme si de rien
n'était c'est pas je veux dire c'est une
honte démocratique et je pense cette
question évidemment c'est l'évidence
mais c'est l'évidence que c'est une
honte démocratique c'est la parole du
président de la république qui a été
engagée sur cette histoire c'est lui
même qui l'a dit je reprendrai tout est
là vous vous asseyez dessus vous êtes le
gouvernement pourtant vous êtes plus
gouvernement du président macron et
venez vous asseoir sur le choix du
président lui même
merci monsieur le député s'il vous plaît
madame la ministre à la parole
monsieur le député rufin j'admire votre
engagement et votre intensité dans votre
réponse qui était près par préalablement
préparé mais j'aimerais que vous
écoutiez j'aime furent édifiés ce que
vous disent que vous voyez la convention
et j'admire votre soutien à la ccc je
conclus donc que vous soutiendrez toutes
ces démarches et que vous saluer le
courage du président de la république et
la démarche qu'il a eue au travers de
cette convention
mais si vous vous reportez bien aux
propositions de la convention les très
clairement dit qu'il faut une évaluation
environnementale et sanitaire que nous
avons que nous faisons est donc je suis
désolé mais c'est très exactement
l'application de cette démarche
méthodologique
nous écoutons nous mettons en oeuvre et
nous améliorons
merci madame la ministre pas écouté 5 g
ou pas il va falloir apprendre à
s'écouter un peu la parole est à madame
sandra motta merci monsieur le président
en ce jour anniversaire de la
disparition de simone veil je souhaite
adresser ma question à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
chargé des affaires européennes madame
amélie de montchanin
il ya ceux qui s'intéressent à la
couleur de la vague de dimanche
et il ya ceux qui tracent le sillon des
20 prochaines années le vrai moment
historique c'est le niveau européen qui
est enfin le vrai moment historique
c'est au niveau européen qu'il est en
train de se dérouler le bon échelon pour
entamer la décarbonation de nos
économies et impulser de la relance de
l'activité c'est au niveau européen la
crise ducobu 19 loin d'acter la mort
sans cesse annoncé et par certains
espérée de l'union européenne nous
invite au contraire à nous rapprocher et
à nous dépasser
la commission européenne a annoncé un
plan de relance inédit de 750 milliards
d'euros
le président de la république et la
chancelière merkel joue un rôle
absolument décisive dans cette
entreprise de conviction intense
l'europe à des dirigeants à la hauteur
de la situation et je crois au vu de
l'actualité internationale que nous
devons nous en féliciter je veux saluer
les intenses efforts diplomatiques du
ministère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères en cours et à venir pour
entraîner ensemble les états membres
dans ce plan de relance
ce seront plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros qui pourront revenir à
notre pays pour annonce pour amorcer la
relance soutenir des emplois modernisée
nos secteurs stratégiques et j'insiste
sur l'investissement indispensable dans
la formation de salariés et dans la
période qui s'ouvre
mais le plan de relance européen n'est
pas une affaire française
c'est une affaire de souveraineté
politique écologique industriels alors
que l'allemagne prend demain la
présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne
il importe d'avoir un horizon sur les
négociations en cours
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous dire
quel est aujourd'hui l'état d'avancement
des échanges relatifs au budget européen
de relance
et quels en seront les contours je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à madame amélie de montchalin
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée oui hier à meseberg nous avons
vécu un moment inédit est décisif pour
la france pour l'allemagne et pour
l'europe inédit parce que c'était la
première fois à la suite de l'initiative
franco allemand du 18 mai dernier que la
france et l'allemagne
ouvrez en commun le chemin de leur
présidence de l'union européenne demain
c'est l'allemagne dans un an et demi ce
sera la france est après trois ans
d'engagement inlassable du président
pour une europe forte souveraine et
solidaire trois ans de travail commun
avec angela merkel
ils ont décidé d'unir leurs forces pour
faire réussir l'europe c'est également
un moment décisif et le calendrier
déterminant car nous avons une
obligation de résultat nous devons unir
les 27 avec un accord en juillet sur la
proposition de budget de la commission
européenne
c'est notre mission commune c'est aussi
la mission que je mène au service du
présent la république
je me suis rendu en autriche aux pays
bas je pars ce soir pour la suède car
nous devons convaincre chaque état
membre que ce plan est bon pour tous les
peuples et pour tous les pays européens
la position de la france pour vous la
connaissez ce budget européen doit être
ambitieux il doit permettre de
reconstruire la souveraineté pour le
climat pour l'agriculture pour la
défense pour le spatial
le plan de relance c'est aux minima a
minima pour nous cinq cents milliards
d'euros de subventions budgétaires c'est
absolument essentiel pour les secteurs
et les régions les plus touchées et nous
pensons que nous devons le faire par un
endettement commun avec des ressources
propres pour le rembourser pour ainsi ne
pas trop alourdir la charge sur les
budgets nationaux
vous savez beaucoup bénéficié l'europe
et n'y contribue pas assez je pense ici
aux pollueurs je pense ici à ceux qui
apportent du plastique je pense à la
taxe sur le carbone la taxe carbone aux
frontières
je pense aux géants du numérique je
pense aux acteurs financiers
ce ne sont pas des nouveaux impôts sur
les ménages et les entreprises ce sont
des ressources pour financer l'europe
ensemble
et sur ce dernier point vous le savez le
parlement français aura en débattre à
l'automne ce sera un moment de
clarification politique trop sur ses
bancs au longtemps étaient des européens
du bout des lèvres à l'automne
ils devront clarifier s'ils sont pour ou
si elles sont contre cette europe forte
que la chancelière et le président
bâtisse à la suite de simone veil et de
beaucoup d'eau de nos pères fondateurs
merci madame
michel victory merci ma question
s'adresse à la ministre du travail
madame la ministre alors que les
intermittents du spectacle attend
toujours un décret attend le dispositif
d'une année blanche promise par le
président de la république et qui nous
avions appelée de nos voeux s'est
toujours dit la voix de plus de 2
millions d'intermittents de l'emploi que
je veux porter le 25 mai au détour d'un
avec parlementaire une mauvaise nouvelle
est tombée pour ses salariés l'année
blanche n'était plus pour eux ils
s'étaient sortis de la nex 4 de
l'assurance chômage est rattachée au
régime général qui ne correspond en rien
à leur réalité la plupart de ses
salariés intermittents dans le secteur
de l'événementiel du tourisme de
l'hôtellerie sent déjà soumis à des
conditions précaires employeurs
multiples contrats de dernière minute
ils sont extra guide conférencier
hôtesse d'accueil chauffeur agent
d'entretien et de sécurité directeur
logistique chargé de production bref ils
sont les maillons précieux d'une chaîne
de savoir faire et de métiers
spécifiques qui font corps avec le monde
de la culture et sans qui les événements
auxquels nous tenons tant n'aurait pas
lieu festivals expositions salons il
officie dans les hôtels dans les salles
de spectacles dans les discothèques qui
ont été les grandes oubliées dans les
ministères et dans les lieux prestigieux
de nos institutions en contrats courts
et en cd et en cdd eu la plupart d'entre
eux n'ont pas pu bénéficier du chômage
partiel ou de fonds de solidarité
fragilisé par votre réforme de
l'assurance chômage il ya vu augmenter
le nombre d'heures nécessaires à une
analyse à sion à 910 heures et dans
l'impossibilité de travailler
ils sont donc privés d'emploi et de
revenus depuis quatre mois
contrairement aux principes mêmes de
notre pacte social
c'est donc une année noire qui se
dessine pour ces femmes et ces hommes à
qui vous n'apportez aucune réponse
aussi madame la ministre nous réclamant
une autre réforme de l'assurance chômage
qui prendra en compte les
caractéristiques très particulières de
ceux de ce travail discontinue ainsi que
la mise en place d'un comité de suivi de
ces discussions
en attendant à quand un décret
correctifs réintégrant ces millions de
personnes dans les annexes 8 et 10 je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues
n'a pas voir l'état monsieur franck
riester ministre de la culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
victory le gouvernement dès le départ de
la crise a accompagné le secteur de la
culture avec force et détermination
c'est la raison pour laquelle il était à
mi temps du spectacle les artistes et
techniciens du secteur de l'audiovisuel
du cinéma et bien sûr du spectacle
vivant ont pu bénéficier du dispositif
d'activité partielle et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le prénom la république le
6 mai comme dans aucun autre pays a pris
la décision très forte de mettre en
place l'année blanche pour ces
intermittents du spectacle qui leur a
permis une prolongation
enfin qui leur permet une prolongation
leurs droits jusqu'au 31 août 2021 leur
permet aussi et bien évidemment de
pouvoir avoir un report des dates
anniversaires au 31 août 2021 leur
permet d'avoir un doublement des
plafonds des heures d'enseignement pris
en compte dans les interviews et bien
évidemment il ya aussi un certain nombre
d'autres professionnels qui travaillent
dans le secteur de la culture de
l'événementiel dans les secteurs que
vous avez rappelé qu'ils ne bénéficient
pas de ces dispositifs spécifiques au
monde de la culture aux artistes et aux
techniciens de l'audiovisuel du cinéma
et de du spectacle vivant et qui sont
pris dans les dispositifs classiques
d'accompagnement du chômage
bien évidemment il y à un certain nombre
de personnes qui sont dans une situation
de précarité très importante c'est la
raison pour laquelle muriel pénicaud et
les équipes du ministère du travail
travail avec leurs représentants pour
trouver des solutions adaptées à leurs
spécificités
le travail est en cours et vous pouvez
compter sur le gouvernement pour
apporter les meilleures réponses à ces
personnes merci monsieur le ministre la
parole à monsieur cyrille isaac sibille
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres collègues ma
question s'adresse aux points ministre
car elle traite d'une thématique qui
grâce à lui un portage interministériel
il s'agit de la santé publique dans
quelques jours le studio de la santé va
formuler des propositions pour refonder
notre système de santé
oui il est évident que l'hôpital doit
être prise en compte
oui les carrières des personnels
soignants devront très valorisé oui
l'hôpital doit être une de nos priorités
mais il ne serait pas la seule car la
crise a montré que c'était avant tout
une crise de santé publique
l'hôpital grâce au dévouement son
personnel a montré qu'ils pouvaient être
agile la santé publique elle n'était pas
prête n'était pas au rendez vous le
premier ministre a montré son
attachement au l'attachement son
gouvernement une politique de santé
publique interministériel notamment
grâce à travers la création d'un comité
interministériel pour la santé dès 2018
mais nous devons aller plus loin plus
vite et je sais que nous partageons ce
même souhaité que la prévention ne soit
plus seulement concept mais une réalité
une réalité pour chacun de nos
concitoyens quelles que soient son âge
et sa condition pour reprendre les
propos des dents philippe sans présager
les propositions de ségur pouvez-vous
nous affirmer que la santé publique ne
sera pas la grande oubliée qu'elle
bénéficiera d'un portage un mig
interministériel encore plus fort et
enfin de moyens financiers pérennes et
bien identifiés je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député c'est isaac sibille je connais
votre détermination vous ne lâchez rien
quand on parle de prévention et santé
publique
semaine après semaine séance après
semaine séance après séance et bien moi
non plus donc je peux vous confirmer
qu'il y aura évidemment un volet santé
publique on peut pas concevoir une
politique structurée de santé sur le
territoire on peut pas concevoir de
vouloir casser les silos ville-hôpital
sanitaire et médico-social en laissant
la santé publique deux côtés on peut pas
faire un retour d'expérience sur la
crise de co vide sans voir que nous
saute aux yeux
le poids des inégalités de santé face à
une épidémie et donc ne pas vouloir
mettre en place de mesures de santé
publique
on ne peut pas considérer et constater
comme vous l'avez fait les difficultés
que nous avons encore d'un système
français nationale vis-à-vis de la
prévention et ne rien faire donc oui il
y aura un volet santé publique il y aura
un volet promotion de la santé
un volet prévention ce que je veux c'est
lutter ardemment contre les inégalités
de santé
ces inégalités craint ce qu'ils font que
l'espérance de vie restent encore trop
importante selon qu'on soit ouvrier ou
qu'on soit cadres dans ce pays que la
mortalité infantile n'est pas la même
dans notre pays que les consommations de
tabac que l'obésité que la malnutrition
frappe non pas indistinctement belle
frappe distinctement les personnes qui
sont le plus en précarité et donc je
veux que ce volet de santé publique
soient véritablement axée sur cette
lutte acharnée déterminée et je l'espère
déterminante contre les inégalités si
monsieur le ministre ce député
merci monsieur le ministre je sais
qu'ensemble nous partageons cette
préoccupation merci d'avoir réaffirmé
donc il ya deux choses premièrement
c'est ce côté interministériel un bien
évidemment c'est la santé et vous
l'apporté mais c'est aussi la transition
écologique pour la santé
environnementale
c'est l'éducation nationale pour
l'éducation à la santé c'est
l'agriculture pour l'alimentation c'est
le sport pour l'exercice physique donc
c'est vraiment interministériel c'est
grâce avec cette ce set actions
interministérielles que nous pourrons
lutter et contrer l'augmentation
inquiétante des maladies chroniques et
des maladies émergentes
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole à monsieur didier quentin
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
il n'est plus là je vais donc la poser à
la madame la ministre d outre-mer madame
la ministre au nom de notre collègue
mansour kamardine je voudrais vous
interroger sur la pandémie de lakovic 19
à mayotte ainsi qu'en guyane
ces deux départements ultra marins sont
en plein pic épidémique avec une
situation sanitaire plus que
préoccupante car ils ont des structures
hospitalières
ils sont déjà saturées en temps normal
s'agissant de mayotte
notre collègue mansour kamardine n'a
cessé de vous alerter sur le décalage
entre la politique sanitaire déclarée et
les moyens déployés réellement sur le
terrain
il signale aussi les tensions
grandissantes du point de vue
sécuritaire et les conséquences
économiques et sociales catastrophiques
de la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
avec la perspective de la disparition de
1000 commerces de proximité à ce jour
aucune réponse concrète n'a été apportée
à la hauteur de la situation mahoraise
pour ce qui est de la guyane les
informations sont tout aussi alarmante
avec une explosion du nombre des
patients touchés par la pandémie en
raison de ses 500 km de voisinage avec
le brésil qui est l'un des trois foyers
les plus importants de la propagation du
virus dans le monde alors madame la
ministre au moment le président de la
république a rappelé que la france
possède le deuxième domaine maritime
mondial grâce à nos collectivités
d'outre-mer ce qui constitue un atout
majeur pour notre pays
pouvez vous nous indiquer les mesures
urgentes que vous entendez prendre pour
renforcer les moyens sanitaires et
sécuritaires
ainsi pour répondre à la crise
économique et sociale à mayotte et en
guyane pour venir en aide aux
populations de notre plus vaste
département et de notre 101e département
merci chers collègues la parole à madame
annick girard 20 ministres d outre-mer
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
compte 1 les situations de guyane et de
meilleurs sont communes parce qu'elles
sont restées effectivement en orange et
nous avons maintenu l'état d'urgence
mais aujourd'hui on peut pas parler
d'une identique situation à mayotte
aujourd'hui les choses vont mieux
je voudrais vous rappeler l'ensemble des
mesures qu'on a mis en place mais ce
qu'il faut rappeler c'est que les choses
vont mieux pourquoi il vaut mieux parce
que on a aujourd'hui
depuis le 2 juin aucun placement en
réanimation pour détresse respiratoire
on a quatre personnes seulement 4
personnes par rapport au nombre de
personnes qu'on a eu au moment du pic
hama
iott je vais donc dire seulement quatre
personnes en réanimation ans il ya à peu
près 20 cas nouveau par jour alors qu'on
était à 80 au moment du pic
et puis nous avons et le ministre de la
santé pourrait on parler mieux que moi
quatre critères pour colorer un
territoire et sur ces quatre critères un
premier est au vert alors oui nous
pouvons avoir de l'espoir aujourd'hui à
mayotte de sortir de cette crise et de
sortir de l'état d'urgence c'est ce que
nous ferons par décret dès que le préfet
la rs et les élus du territoire nous
demanderons pour la guyane
nous sommes tout à fait à linverse
aujourd'hui le virus circule et circule
beaucoup
nous avons même un pic prévu pour autour
de la mi juillet fin juillet à mayotte
aujourd'hui beaucoup de renforts sont
arrivés c'est plus de 200 personnes qui
sont venues sur le territoire nous avons
mille tests par jour c'est plus haut que
la moyenne nationale nous avons plus de
2 millions de masques nous avons les
équipements et les moyens sur place pour
lutter contre ce virus par quand nous
n'avons pas assez de ressources humaines
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 200 soignants
qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui en guyane et
je veux profiter de prendre la parole
devant vous tous mesdames et messieurs
les députés pourra faire un appel
solennel et national à la solidarité
solidarité des territoires d'outre-mer
solidarité nationale plus de 200 même
300 soignants qu'il nous faut il faut
qu'on soit à ce rendez vous j'appelle
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui ont fait déjà
beaucoup d'efforts sur le plan national
dans l'hexagone et à mayotte à se rendre
aujourd'hui en guyane et à venir
répondre aux appels de l'hôpital et de
de ce territoire
je voudrais aussi vous dire que nous
avons mis en place un 400m et je veux
remercier le ministère des armées air
suivies d'évacuations sanitaires sur les
enfants autonomes barbara baisse au balo
même si président madame la ministre
acteurs d'une économie à taille humaine
souvent familiales générateur de lien
social et de vitalité dans nos villages
et dans nos centres bourgs vecteur de
savoir-faire maillon indispensable qui
contribue à une création de valeur
équitable et de qualité nos artisans nos
commerçants de proximité des
indépendants sont essentiels à
l'attractivité et au dynamisme de nos
territoires
alors que certains s'en sont très bien
sortis lors de cette période inédit je
pense aux fromages et aux bouchers
locaux il va sans dire que d'autres
secteurs d'activités du commerce ont été
durement éprouvés confinés dans nos
circonscriptions
nous sommes collectivement rester
mobilisés aux côtés de ses forces vives
de nos territoires afin d'appréhender au
mieux leurs difficultés et de vous faire
part dans l'urgence des remontées de
terrain pour que les mesures
d'accompagnement reflète au mieux les
besoins
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui dans cet
hémicycle je tiens à saluer d'une part
l'action du gouvernement pour soutenir
dès le premier jour où notre pays a
basculé dans l'état d'urgence sanitaire
nos artisans et commerçants d'autre part
votre annonce récente madame la ministre
d'un plan de relance en faveur de
l'artisanat du petit commerce et des
indépendants les entreprises de
l'artisanat et du commerce de proximité
ont entretenu durant cette période
inédit chaque fois leur futur pourrait
ressembler circuit turc our numérisation
de l'acte d'achat
l'intérêt pour les initiatives
solidaires durable et local
madame la ministre partout sur le
territoire nous artisans commerçants et
indépendants seront à même apporté la
transformation en profondeur de
l'économie de cette crise a rendu
incontournable et à l'heure où le
commerce et l'artisanat proximité
constitue l'une des clés pour leurs
larves et utilisation de nos centres
bourgs le dynamisme et la richesse de
nos territoires pouvez vous s'il vous
plaît nous éclairer sur les grandes
lignes du plan de relance pour
l'artisanat le petit commerce et des
indépendants et notamment sur les
mesures à mettre en oeuvre pour les
accompagner dans la transition vers une
économie de proximité à la fois
compétitive
merci le député la parole à monsieur
bruno le maire -ministre de l'économie
et des finances monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée bababé ce vélo nous avons
fait beaucoup pour les commerçants pour
les indépendants pour les professions
libérales et nous allons faire encore
plus parce que c'est eux qui ont été le
plus touchés par la crise et c'est eux
qui ont le plus de mal aujourd'hui à
remonter la pente
ce que les clients qui ne sont pas venus
pendant trois mois ou quatre mois les
commerces qui ont été fermés ne récupère
pas leur chiffre d'affaires du jour au
lendemain
donc je crois que c'est une question de
justice de soutien tous nos territoires
de soutenir encore davantage dans le
plfr 3 les commerçants les artisans et
les indépendants première mesure un
soutien à la trésorerie
nous allons prolonger pour un mois
supplémentaire
le fonds de solidarité pour l'ensemble
de ceux qui peuvent en bénéficier
commerçants indépendants ou artisans
nous allons également simplifier l'accès
au deuxième étage je fonce solidarité
celui qui permet de bénéficier de 10000
euros est donc très concrètement de
payer son loyer parce que beaucoup de
commerçants n'ont plus de ressources
pour payer leur loyer
ils pourront désormais avoir accès de
manière beaucoup plus facile à ce
deuxième étage pour être très concret
n'auront plus besoin de montrer qu'on
leur a refusé un prêt garanti par l'état
pour avoir accès à ce deuxième étage
2e série mesure de vos longs revitaliser
les centre-bourgs revitaliser les
commerces de village et pour ça nous
allons créer sans foncière qui vont
acheter civile commerce dans les cinq
prochaines années qui vont les acheter
les retaper les moderniser peut-être
faut rassembler deux ou trois pièces
pour faire un commerce qui soit plus
acceptable évidemment garantir aussi la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments et
ensuite les relouer un tarif
préférentiel aux commerçants qui
seraient intéressés c'est la meilleure
façon de revitaliser les commerces de
centre-ville
enfin troisième série de mesures il faut
digitalisées massivement les commerçants
la crise a montré que les commerçants
qui s'en sortent le mieux c'est ce
qu'ils sont digitalisées nous les ont
aidés des plus tôt d'artificial ise les
entrées de ville mieux vaut revitaliser
les commerces de centre-ville
ni monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur hubert wulfranc bien monsieur
le président entre messieurs du
gouvernement je reviens parce que c'est
impressionnant
c'est impressionnant la manière dont
vous réduisez à néant en quelques heures
les propositions des citoyens pour un
financement juste d'une transition
solidaire et écologique
premier acte dès hier le président
lui-même et cartes d'une phrase la
proposition de ses citoyens de taxer à
hauteur 4%
les dividendes de plus de 10 millions
d'euros versés par les grandes
entreprises celles du cac 40
c'est à dire près de 60 milliards
l'année dernière total lafarge sanofi
danone vivant dit j'en passe donc ça
y'est profit écarté deuxième acte ce
matin monsieur le ministre de l'économie
qui rejette la proposition de baisser la
tva de 10 à 5 5 sur les billets de
trains favoriser une fréquentation
accrue et bien du ferroviaire pour vous
ces noms circulez ya rien à voir
tenez puisqu'on est dans le ferroviaire
parenthèse 2 milliards de recettes sur
les dividendes par an c'est répondre au
plan d'investissement pour le fret
marchandises chiffré à hauteur de 13
milliards d'ici 2030 par les acteurs du
rail un plan remis à monsieur le
ministre à monsieur le secrétaire d'état
des transports qui n'est pas sûr sur ses
bancs alors combien de vos ministres
vont défiler dans les médias ou ici même
à l'exemple de madame panier une hache
et tout à l'heure pour si une à une les
branches de la transformation sociale et
environnementale à laquelle aspirent les
français bien dit nous le tout de suite
merci monsieur le député la parole à
monsieur olivier du secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'action et des comptes
publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs député monsieur le député
wulfranc monsieur le député je ne sais
pas si je défile devant vous dans cet
hémicycle où dans les médias pour
évoquer les propositions formulées par
les 150 citoyens tirés au sort ce que je
voudrais simplement vous dire c'est
peut-être deux choses d'abord dire en
écho à ce qu'on dit mes collègues qui
sont exprimés précédemment que cette
contribution de citoyens et une
contribution utile
le président de la république a indiqué
hier qu'il reprenait à son compte
l'essentiel des propositions formulées
que le parlement allait être saisie de
ses propositions parce que le parlement
c'est l'incarnation de la démocratie
représentative et le lieu de la décision
politique que le gouvernement était lui
aussi chargé de la mise en oeuvre des
propositions et il a même évoqué la
possibilité si c'était nécessaire de
consulter le peuple français
par ailleurs c'est le deuxième point sur
lequel je veux insister
vous savez que nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble de mes collègues ministres
secrétaires d'état à bercy mais plus
largement avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement sur la préparation d'un
plan de relance
ce plan de relance nous le voulons fort
nous louons ambitieux nous le voulons
autour de l'économie de l'emploi
nous le voulons autour de la question
sociale et de l'accompagnement de celles
et ceux qui sont les plus fragilisés
nous le voulons aussi auto la transition
écologique et je puis vous assurer que
les propositions qui sont importés par
les 150 citoyens sont aussi des sources
d'inspiration que nous allons en tenir
compte que nous allons les intégrer je
permettais moi cette affirmation
pardonnez moi c'est presque injonction
sortez-vous de la tête s'il vous plaît
monsieur le député le fait que nous
serions là pour essayer
les branches de la convention citoyenne
une à une nous avons dit que nous
reprenons notre compte nous avons dit
que nous avons besoin d'expertisé nous
avons dit qu'il y en avait quelques unes
d'entre elles qui ne correspondait pas à
la logique politique qui était la nôtre
mais le travail qui a été fait une
aventure démocratique extraordinaire il
sera valorisé il sera mise à profit
merci monsieur brice monsieur wulfranc
wii 2 secondes et donc
vous êtes inspiré par une augmentation
de la taxe aux gaffes à vous êtes
inspiré par un impôt écologique sur la
fortune rénové est-ce que cirque a tout
simplement est ce que c'est le cas
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur loïc dombreval je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le président
cette question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche et de l'innovation
nous venons de l'évoquer le décret
publié le 17 mars 2001 liées à
l'approvisionnement des animaux utilisés
à des fins d'expérimentation a déclenché
une vive émotion largement relayée et
amplifiée par les réseaux sociaux et les
médias cela pas été signalée par notre
collègue le goût le doubs mais il faut
noter que ce décret double le nombre de
représentants de la protection animale
au sein de la commission nationale de
l'expérimentation animale
je vous remercie madame la ministre
d'avoir précisé la réalité de vos
intentions d'avoir levé toute ambiguïté
sur la modification de l'article r 214
tiré 90 du code rural et d'avoir rassuré
les associations et nos concitoyens en
confirmant qu'il reste bien illégal est
impossible pour un laboratoire
d'utiliser des animaux volés cédé ou
vendu par des particuliers
au-delà de cette nécessaire
éclaircissement notre échange d'être
également l'occasion d'affirmer que la
règle dite des trois r qui consiste à
réduire et raffiné l'utilisation
d'animaux d'expérimentation et elle est
remplacée par des méthodes alternatives
peut être appliquée de façon beaucoup
plus volontariste en france à l'image
par exemple de nos voisins anglais oui
la france doit se doter de moyens plus
importants pour développer l'application
de la règle des 3 r et autant que cela
est possible les méthodes alternatives à
l'expérimentation sur les animaux
pouvez vous nous dire mais la ministre
où en est notre pays sur la mise en
oeuvre de cette règle essentielle en
expérimentation animale qui consiste
donc à réduire raffiné et remplacés
merci j'ai recollé avec la parole est
valable frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
loïc dombreval je tire plusieurs
enseignements de cet emballement
médiatique et de cet emballement sur les
réseaux sociaux vous venez de rappeler
tout d'abord le fait que le dialogue
avec les associations de protection
animale et reste absolument essentiel la
fondation brigitte bardot la fondation
droit animal éthique et sciences deux
fondations membres du comité national de
l'expérimentation animale ont très tôt
souligné la mauvaise interprétation du
décret du 17 mars et c'était évidemment
d'autant plus respectable de leur part
que ces associations avaient évidemment
été consultée au moment où nous avons
modifié ce décret ça nous a confortés
aussi lors de ces discussions dans notre
volonté d'ouvrir plus avant encore le
dialogue avec ces associations
mais c'est pourquoi vous l'avez rappelé
nous avons doublé la représentation des
associations de protection au sein de la
cmu âme dans le même décret du 17 mars
mais cela est encore insuffisant
notre pays est un acteur majeur de la
recherche en biologie et en santé il ne
peut pas se satisfaire d'une opposition
stérile entre recours à l'animal
méthodes alternatives donc oui nous
porterons la règle des 3 r que vous
venez d'évoquer ses méthodes
alternatives sont aujourd'hui les
méthodes prédominante dans les
laboratoires le recours à l'animal n'est
envisagée que lorsqu'il faut se
confronter à la complexité du vivant et
nous en avons encore eu un exemple tout
récemment avec la crise du coc vide
c'est une approche qui demeure essentiel
dans certains cas que l'on parle de
santé humaine ou que l'on parle
d'ailleurs de santé animale c'est
pourquoi mon ministère en lien étroit
avec les ministères chargés de
l'agriculture et de l'écologie travaille
sur trois aspects d'abord la mise en
lumière de la réalité des pratiques de
nos chercheurs
ensuite la promotion nécessaire des
méthodes alternatives et enfin
l'instruction des jeunes qui auront à
les pratiquer tout cela sera présenté
l'automne la parole est à madame valérie
beauvais merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur les
forces de l'ordre subissent en moyenne
107 agressions par jour
nos policiers et gendarmes exerce une
mission difficile et contrairement au
procès terriblement injuste que certains
leur font ils agissent avec
professionnalisme et sang froid et sont
exemplaires dans leur engagement au
service de nos compatriotes
ils auront été en première ligne lors de
toutes les manifestations des gilet
jaune où ils auront dû gérer les
débordements répétés de casseurs ils
auront été en première ligne au moment
des attentats et l'auront parfois payé
de leur vie
oui il nous faut soutenir sans faille
nos forces de l'ordre parce qu'ils sont
eux aussi nos héros du quotidien et
parce qu'il n'ya pas de liberté sans
sécurité
pas d'état de droit sans ordre
républicain pourtant les forces de
l'ordre se sentent oubliés et méprisés
il doute quand ils entendent des
irresponsables prenaient leur
désarmement ou les remettre en cause
il doute quand ils sont tous pointés du
doigt pour les fautes d'une infime
minorité
il doute quand le gouvernement refuse de
leur payer leurs heures supplémentaires
ou tardent à le faire et enfin il doute
quand ils ont le sentiment d'être lâché
par leur ministre alors monsieur le
ministre depuis votre nomination vos
réponses se limite à commenter l'action
des gouvernements d'il ya près de 10 ans
ou à vouloir interdire une techniques
d'interpellation puisque je sais que
vous allez nous renvoyer à notre bilan
je vous renvoie au vôtre celui des notes
de service que vous commandez pour
entraver limiter l'action des policiers
et des gendarmes pour ne pas faire de
bruit ne pas faire de vagues
monsieur le ministre vous dit soutenir
sans ambiguïté les forces de l'ordre
mais nous vous attendons toujours sur
les actes alors quels actes entendez
vous prendre pour montrer l'attachement
et la reconnaissance de la nation à nos
forces de l'ordre
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs 10 pts et madame la
députée bové des actes oui les heures
supplémentaires
il y avait une dette du ministère pour
certaines heures supplémentaires qui
datait de 2005
et je ne vois pas du passé mais juste le
début je suis le premier ministre madame
la députée qui a fait en sorte de
pouvoir payer une partie de cette dette
non seulement j'ai mobilisé près de 50
millions d'euros pour payer une partie
de cette dette qui datait depuis 2005
dans certains cas mais en plus pour la
première fois dans le budget 2009 1 que
vous n'avez pas voté nous avons doté en
plus la police d'un volet d'heures
supplémentaires c'est une première pour
faire en sorte que justement le stock ne
se reproduisent pas à l'infini des actes
madame la députée c'est un milliard
d'euros 1 milliards d'euros
d'augmentation du budget pour la
sécurité intérieure depuis 2007 les
actes madame la députée ses 10000
recrutement qui ont été engagés et qui
seront en totalement recruté à la fin du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron voilà
madame la députée quelques actes mais la
réalité elle est plus profonde et je ne
voudrais pas polémique est contrairement
à vous sur le sujet du soutien que nous
devons de la reconnaissance que mérite
effectivement nos policiers et nos
gendarmes à chaque instant mais ça doit
madame la députée se traduire par des
actes concrets et pas seulement par des
incantations des déclarations vous avez
parlé de ses 107 agression je peux
parler de cette moyenne 30 policiers qui
chaque jour sont blessés dans l'exercice
de leurs fonctions quelques fois de
façon involontaire mais quelquefois
aussi de façon volontaire de cette
agression qui monte face à nos forces de
sécurité
et quand on regarde entre 2019 et 2018
de cette progression de près de 6 % d
agression contre nos policiers
c'est un phénomène uniquement nationale
il est important de prendre du recul
vous avez vu ces images récemment à
londres
j'ai changé avec orci offer le ministre
allemand il ya peu de temps en allemagne
l'année dernière ses 46 % d'augmentation
d agression contre nos forces de
sécurité donc nous devons les mieux
armés nous devons les protéger
nous devons faire en sorte qu'ils soient
mieux équipée notamment caméra piétons
et c'est un engagement que je prends et
nous devrons faire en sorte qu'ils aient
des moyens d'agir des véhicules et
d'immobilier correct pour vivre est ce
que nous faisons
jay ferment madame député est
certainement une révolution quant à
notre engagement parlera parce que merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement doit assumer
ses responsabilités ne pas se défausser
sur les autres
la colère inédite des forces de l'ordre
c'est aujourd'hui et je vous rappelle
que le groupe l'est républicain avait
proposé par l'intermédiaire d'eric
ciotti d'adopter une proposition de loi
pour augmenter les moyens consacrés à la
sécurité de 15 milliards d'euros sur six
ans et c'est ce même gouvernement cette
même majorité qui l'a refusée alors nous
n'avons sûrement pas de leçon à recevoir
d'un gouvernement qui aura été si
injuste avec nos forces de l'ordre
sylvain le député la parole à monsieur
jean félix acquaviva ma question
s'adresse à madame ministre en charge
des collectivités territoriales madame
jacqueline gourault madame la ministre
la crise des gilets jaunes actes et déjà
la nécessité d'une rupture radicale avec
une pole une politique jugée trop
vertical jacobine technocrates qui ne
correspondaient pas aux aspirations
économiques sociales environnementales
des populations certes la loi engagement
proximité est passée par là et à donner
plus de prérogatives aux maires et c'est
une bonne chose mais trop souvent le
couple préfet maire a été mise en
exergue et mis en exergue en opposition
avec les autres collectivités
territoriales dans leurs prérogatives
déjà conféré par la loi au niveau des
départements des régions et des
collectivités à statut particulier
cela est une anomalie est dangereux d'un
point de vue démocratique est inutile
inefficace du point de vue des
politiques publiques
à l'heure où la crise sanitaire démontré
la réactivité des territoires sur le
plan la santé du médico social
à l'heure où la crise économique et
sociale des finances publiques qui salon
sera sans précédent voire cataclysmique
nous pensons avec le groupe liberté et
territoires que le temps est venu d'un
véritable acte de décentralisation
politique qui permette enfin par le
débat une clarification des compétences
et des moyens entre ce qui doit être du
registre de l'état central dans les
domaines où il est attendu
bien sûr l'hôpital public la sécurité la
justice le pénitentiaire et dieu sait
qui est des demandes et du domaine des
collectivités territoriales qui doivent
agir
sur le plan de la proximité du
développement de la maison un territoire
de l'économie circulaire de la
transition énergétique du logement du
transport leur de leur relocalisation
des systèmes de production nécessite ce
débat nécessite d'aller au bout pour le
bien de ce pays pour le bien de nos
territoires
aussi ma question est très simple quand
et selon quel calendrier allez vous
mettre en oeuvre ce processus
et comment allez vous vous y prendre
allez vous associer l'ensemble des
acteurs politiques économiques et
sociaux pour qu'enfin il ya eu un
consensus politique fort à la hauteur
des enjeux dans ce domaine je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame jacqueline gourault ministre de
la cohésion de territoire et des
relations et les collectivités
territoriales
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député jean-félix à quoi vivent
j'ai bien entendu votre question et je
répond de façon très simple en disant
que vous savez très bien j'ai entamé au
début de l'année une concertation sur le
terrain avec les élus les forces de la
société civile et que ces concertations
ont donné lieu à un travail y compris
pendant la période de confinement avec
les associations d'élus et mon
expérience d'élu je dirais
personnellement m'a amené à penser
qu'effectivement la décentralisation
était une chose très importante mais ma
conviction partagée avec beaucoup d'élus
c'est que la prochaine étape de la
décentralisation réside aussi dans la
différenciation je sais monsieur le
député que vous ne me contredirez pas
sur ce point la corse en est un parfait
exemple pour rapidement donner corps à
ce principe
le premier ministre a transmis mardi
dernier au conseil d'état un projet de
loi organique relative aux
expérimentations territoriales
la différenciation territoriales dont
les premiers jalons seront posées par ce
projet de loi mettra fin à la conclusion
binaire c'est à dire vous savez
généralisation ou abandon au terme des
expérimentations de manière à pouvoir
les pérenniser
dans certains territoires dans un pays
construit depuis plus de deux siècles
sur l'uniformisation
c'est évidemment une petite révolution
par ailleurs j'ai été surprise de votre
propos sur l'alliance préfets maires
c'est bien sûr la proximité qui a
derrière cette expression qui est
revendiqué par tout le monde mais qui ne
se fait pas contre les autres
la proximité c'est aussi au niveau d'un
département
la proximité entre le président du
conseil départemental et le préfet il
faut arrêter de toujours construire
quand on dit quelque chose que c'est
contre les autres c'est avec les autres
monsieur le député merci madame la
ministre
la séance des questions au gouvernement
et terminer la séance est suspendue